Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Oh, shit.
I'm so loud.
I'm so sorry.
Whoa, I'm so sorry.
Let me... I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm at 98.
Whoa, okay.
That should be better.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize how loud I was.
I was like at 98.
I was like, why the fuck am I at 98?
Anyway, guys.
Hello, everybody.
I am currently unpacking the Marvel Rivals right now.
I am at 12.13 gigabytes out of 47.
Apparently, when you preload the game...
When you preload the game, it like...
It doesn't guarantee... It's not like fully downloaded.
You gotta unpack it at the exact time.
So, we're at currently... We're 15 gigabytes down.
AstroGuy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I find it suspicious that Doki is right on time for stream when it's a release of Overwatch.
I mean Marvel Rivals.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean...
I need a new addiction, guys.
I can't keep relapsing into Overwatch.
I need something new.
Also, I realized I forgot to write that down.
I'm... Okay.
I uploaded a short that was like, I'm a mess.
And someone in the chat... I saw someone in the comments that was like, Doki, why are you not a mess?
Anyway, I'm a little bit of a mess right now.
Because there are like multiple things I forgot to do regarding this particular stream.
So, at the end of the stream, there's gonna be a special announcement.
I won't spoil what it is.
Member goons might know what it is.
Because I did give a little hint as to what the announcement is.
So, it's gonna be announced at the end of the stream.
So, you guys gotta stick it to the end, basically.
And it's a very cool announcement.
It's a very happy announcement, too.
And then...
What else do I have to say?
That's it.
Oh, yeah.
So, there's an announcement at the end of the stream.
I forgot to say... I forgot to be more public about it.
I literally changed the title of the stream.
I think like four hours before I was supposed to start.
And I ended up forgetting to...
I forgot to tweet that out.
So, three hours before the stream was supposed to start, I was like, By the way, there's gonna be an announcement.
And some people were like...
So, there's no really heads up for people.
I also posted the wrong link to the waiting room.
Because what I do for waiting rooms, I just copy and paste.
And then just like... I just go copy and paste.
And then bam.
And then change the links and everything.
I forgot to change the link to the stream itself.
And I usually schedule my... I schedule my waiting room tweets.
Because I try to make sure it tweets out seven hours before the stream is supposed to start.
So, then like... I would be sleeping when that happens.
So, usually I'm not awake when the waiting room tweets go up.
You know when I'm awake when it tells like...
You know when I'm on Twitter and I'm awake when I also link the art of the thumbnail.
That's when you know that I was awake when I made that tweet.
When there's no like instant link to the artist of the thumbnail.
That's when you know I am definitely asleep.
I was not there.
I'm not alive at that time.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Evening Doki, it's my friend and fellow Dragoon Melphie's birthday today.
If you can tease her a little and say happy birthday.
I'm sure she'll instantly pass out later when she sees the VOD.
Happy birthday Mel.
Alright, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mel.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Okay, life update.
I talked about this before in the member stream.
So, I'll say here for those who are not membered.
So, we have a new neighbor.
This is basically the same thing I told in the member stream yesterday.
I don't know if you guys want to hear the story again.
So, we have a new neighbor.
They have a dog.
And I don't know what this dog looks like.
But, you can tell what type of dog breed they are based on their barks.
So, like, this particular dog breed.
I am 99% sure it's one of those stupid...
I'm sorry, I've yelled one of them.
It's one of those...
Like, you know what I'm talking about.
They have a very distinct bark.
So, the... I'm sorry if my neighbor hears this.
But, like, basically, there's this new neighbor who has a toy poodle.
I've never seen this dog before.
But, I have absolutely heard that dog barking.
And the worst part about it is that...
Hey, my dog is half toy.
So, the worst part about it is that this toy poodle would bark randomly almost every day.
And because they would bark randomly almost every day, they'd be like...
I have to deal with Doki Amber Doge barking back at them.
Because he's like, who the fuck is this bitch?
So, it ended up causing this infinite loop of barking at each other through a door.
Because, like, I don't know, through two doors.
Because, like, then the other dog, the toy poodle is like, who's this other guy barking at me?
And they just go like...
It's just a loop.
It's a fucking loop.
They don't stop.
And the only way I could stop the barking...
Because this happens, like, almost every day now.
Because, like, you know, she starts and then my dog hears her.
And then he starts going at it.
And then she hears him.
So, she continues and it's an infinite loop.
It's just negative feedback.
So, I learned that the only way to stop this from happening is that...
I had to dig through my boxes and I found his training collar.
And I don't put it on him.
But when he sees me hold that training collar, he fucking walks away.
He's just like, oh shit.
And then he just walks back.
He's just like...
So...
He walks back and it stops.
Until...
So, the loop stops.
So...
So, I have to do that now.
I literally have, like, his training collar, like, next to me.
In case, like, he starts walking over to the door and starts the loop again.
And the moment he starts the fucking loop, I have to, like, go outside.
Like, go to the door and show him the collar.
And he just walks back.
And he's like, okay, I'm gonna stop.
Okay, I'll stop.
I'm sorry.
It's literally the only way.
Like, cause the toy poodle doesn't stop.
Like, she could go on forever.
Like, I can only stop what I see right now.
So...
So, yes.
I had to, unfortunately...
I had to, unfortunately, use his PTSD against him.
So, like, we could all be happy.
I don't put it on him.
I just let him see it.
So, he could, like, just the memories flash through him.
Anyway, guys.
Marvel Rivals!
I am super excited to finally try out Marvel Rivals.
We've been in...
We've been in, like, uh...
The beta test.
We were in the beta test.
We were in the alpha test.
And finally, we get to play on launch day!
What I'm most excited about, um...
Marvel Rivals.
Uh, for the launch date.
Is the fact that they are launching 32 new...
Like, 32 characters.
Which is absolutely insane if you think about it.
Because that's a lot of new characters.
Um, and I think, like...
Um...
What's crazy...
Oh, 33.
Sorry.
I was one short.
33 characters.
Um, because, like, you know, when we first played the alpha and the beta...
There wasn't a lot of, like, characters unlocked.
But now there's 33!
Going straight in on launch day!
And they're all available, like, now.
So, like, it's not like...
Um, it's like pay to win or anything.
You can actually get all of them now.
Without having to wait for it.
And then my favorite thing about it is that, like, people are like...
Oh...
Not my favorite thing, but, like...
What I find the most funny...
Is that people were like...
Oh...
Okay, also this guy is funny, too.
I...
I gotta show you Mr. Fantastic, by the way.
I showed this in the members.
But, like, this is what Mr. Fantastic looks like.
Um, with his alt form.
And, okay, so...
That's honestly one of my favorite pictures.
And...
But, like, people were like...
Oh my god.
They're gonna steal more than just...
Uh, they're gonna steal...
Um, a lot of...
More than just the Overwatch...
Um, player base.
They're gonna steal the Overwatch...
Gooner base.
Okay, what the fuck...
Do you mean by that?
Well, um...
If you guys don't know...
If you guys did not know...
What, um...
Um, what the characters...
Sort of look like...
Uh, they have a...
Particular visual about them.
So...
Um, they...
Aw, man, what can I say about them?
They are...
Aw, man, I had the pictures, but I don't...
I didn't save them.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me see if I can find it.
Uh, Marvel Rivals...
Women.
I wonder if I could, like...
Get, like, the entire...
The compilation.
Oh, I can't.
Alright, so, like...
Okay, I can show you Squirrel...
Squirrel Girl.
And then, you know, I can show her, like...
On the game.
Like, I don't even need a fucking...
Why am I Googling it?
I can literally boot up the game.
Like, give me a sec.
Let me boot it up.
I don't know why I tried to show...
Why did I didn't get...
Get a picture?
I can literally boot up the game...
And show it to you guys, cause I...
Cause it's already done.
Um...
It's already... Okay, your system is using...
Unlocked Intel 13...
Or 14th Gen Desktop CPU.
And you're experiencing...
I'm not, right?
There's no way.
I don't think I am.
Okay, launch.
I don't remember if I am.
We'll see, right?
We'll see.
Yeah, I'm super excited.
The only issue I have about this...
Is the fact that it is...
In third person.
So, um...
Oh yeah, I'm on AMD now.
I forgot.
I'm on AMD.
We had an issue with Marvel Rivals...
Because I was on Intel.
It's just the fact that...
Um...
I'm not like a big fan of third person in general.
When it comes to like competitive.
Like, I'm okay with...
Third person for like...
A fun, just like...
Um...
Not try hard type of game and just like...
Head empty type thing.
But rank wise...
Rank wise, I am not like...
I'm not a huge fan of third person for rank.
Just because I feel like...
It's not as...
It doesn't feel as competitive for me.
I feel like first person...
Increases the competitiveness.
And increases like the more intensity...
Of like...
Shooters in general.
But, we'll see.
Cause like I was talking to like...
Some of my friends about it.
And they were saying how like...
Also like I'm compiling shaders.
And that's why I'm lagging right now.
And they're saying that like...
It might be fun for like maybe like...
A couple of days.
But it could like you know...
You know...
It's hard to be competitive if it's like...
If they don't give the same feeling.
As feeling.
So I don't know.
We'll see.
We'll see how we feel.
I do enjoy it.
Because I played the alpha test and the beta test.
And I really really enjoyed...
The alpha and the beta test.
But I was also fucking around a lot.
So...
I mean...
Literally I was like...
Clap to heal!
Clap everybody!
Now dance everyone!
Dance to heal!
Like I was not...
I was not taking it very seriously.
I was like keep clapping!
Woo!
Hmm...
So yeah we'll see.
We'll see how I feel.
I haven't seen Psylocke look that kicked up since the Capcom Arcades are going for the SFM artists.
Not just the gamers.
It's time to reboot Patreon!
Everybody!
It's time!
Okay...
Can I be like my...
Has anyone claimed my name yet?
Oh!
For once I can actually be my name.
That's crazy.
Usually I like have like the most dumb ass names.
Because everybody would claim it.
For once I can actually be me.
Like...
Alright so...
Let's check out the new...
Where's Psylocke?
Where is she?
Oh there she is.
Okay that's not Psylocke.
I'm talking about Squirrel Girl.
So yeah.
Yeah.
It's time to...
Woah.
It's...
It's time to...
Re-pledge to Patreon guys.
Possessing only a power...
But somehow during the rematch defeat...
Wait what do you... Woah.
Oh my god.
We're back to the...
The 50s with her.
That's cute.
Wait this is so cute.
I heard the Battle Pass...
Okay one of the things I actually liked...
About...
One of the things I actually liked...
About the...
The Marble Rivals...
Thing they did with cosmetics...
Is that if you buy the Battle Pass...
You're not forced to...
Get to the end of the Battle Pass...
In a specific time.
There's no time limit for Battle Passes.
So there's no FOMO.
So you can take your time to unlock everything if you want to.
So that's what I like.
And they said that...
For cosmetics right now...
You can play...
To unlock cosmetics.
So you don't have to actually spend money.
For now.
I don't know.
I don't know if they'll change though.
So like...
Who knows?
Things could be different.
But...
It's not a skip.
Look I've been through a lot when it comes to like...
Battle Passes and cosmetics.
So like hearing that is actually like...
It's actually...
Really different from how other video games do it.
Yeah, it's a free game.
Yeah, I feel like...
They do that just to make you like...
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I have to...
I gotta check it out now.
Okay, this is the one that everybody was...
Oh, that's the default skin?
Oh, so this is the newer one.
This is the cosmetic that you have to buy.
Oh...
I wonder if I have to change my...
Controls.
I actually didn't check that.
Um...
Alright, what is her abilities?
Using crossbow...
To damage enemies...
And reduce the cooldown of all her abilities.
Slash nearby enemies with katana.
Ooh!
Wait, that's sick.
Stash forward and slice through enemies.
The thing is, she's melee.
And I'm not like a melee person though.
Um...
Oh, I heard Black Widow is Widowmaker.
Is basically Widowmaker.
And that it's like...
She's like stronger than Widowmaker too.
As a sniper.
Alright, let's see.
What's her MVP?
This is basically like play of the game.
Okay.
I like how...
I like where she's facing.
Widow, strike with the enemy...
Electron...
Okay, enhanced electric...
Baton.
Attack with the...
Apparently this shit is really strong.
There's the...
Damaging enemies when leaving a plasma on the ground.
Oh shit!
That is so strong!
Stash forward and enable a powerful jump.
Okay, that's like high jump.
Unleash a spinning kick to launch up enemies.
Landing hit will allow her to zip to the target with a grappling hook for a second kick.
This is like melee Widow.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Okay, and that's the...
That's the Widowmaker.
And apparently if you have...
A Marvel Hanzo...
As in Hawkeye...
You get like...
Walls.
Widow if she can fight back.
Yeah, so you duo with a Hawkeye...
You can get like...
Basically walls from him.
Which is scary.
Which is...
The wall, yeah.
You get to have wall hacks and stuff.
Where the fuck are you?
I'm still looking.
So, I guess...
There's Black Widow, Cloak, and Dat Cloak.
Wait, that's not fair!
There are two people!
How is this fair?
Also, who are they?
That's also another question.
Who are they?
That's not fair!
This is like a 1v2, what do they do?
Oh wait, she's a support?
Oh!
Okay, so this is an Ana heal.
You gotta hit them, they heal them.
Perform three rapid dashes, healing allies and damaging allies along the path.
Wait, what?
Okay, so...
Do I run into them?
I basically heal them.
Switch to Cloak.
What happens if I switch to him?
The fuck does that do?
I'm just...
Cool.
Now she...
Now she has a Cloak.
Okay.
It doesn't even say!
The fuck does Shadow Brace does?
Oh, there we go!
Okay, alright, I was gonna be like...
Wait, that's so compli...
Okay, that's a lot for my brain.
I didn't realize I can actually swap to him.
Okay, he's a damage character, basically.
Perform three...
Okay, no, he can still heal.
He can still heal.
And then...
Oh my god, that's way too much thinking.
Okay, I hope he's not meta.
I...
Yeah, this is like a high skill cap.
Oh my god.
Okay, cause like you gotta be able to juggle between two different characters as you play.
So like...
The game literally just came out 25 minutes ago.
There's no way he's...
There is no way.
How is this a three star difficulty?
This is two heroes at once.
At once!
Okay.
So I can basically make...
Wait, okay, so like if we all group up together, I can make everybody invisible.
Create light where night can become invisible.
Okay, so this is base...
Where's my ult then?
Do I have an ult?
Oh, I guess it's the eternal...
No.
Wait, what is my ult?
Is my Q, right?
Perform three... Is the three rapid dashes?
Okay, I guess that's the ult.
Creating a healing over time field in the impact area.
Okay, so this is a damage one.
A terror cape damages people and like makes damage boosts.
So this damage boosts and then this one gives a healing boost.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I hope she's not meta.
I...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
We'll figure it out.
Then we have Iron Fist.
This guy's four star.
He has... Oh my...
I was gonna say, this guy's four star.
He's one guy.
And then I see like one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten abilities.
Okay.
This is...
You're literally playing...
You're literally playing a fighting game at that point.
You're...
It's literally... Look at all these combos you can do.
Alright.
Oh, he can wall run.
He has more moves than a character that has literally two in one.
Oh my... Guys, I know what I'm not... There's suggested combos?
Oh my god.
That can be like...
Okay.
Alright.
So...
So there is...
All that stuff.
Okay.
And then we have Jeff the Shark.
I saw the trailer for this guy before.
He's so cute.
He's really cute.
What does he do?
Where is his com... Oh my god.
The fuck is that?
Incognito Dolphin?
Wait...
It's like...
I'm... The brightest thing on the fucking map.
Alright.
Joyful Splash.
Oh, he's easy.
Unleash a heal... Oh, he's also a healer.
There's so many supports now.
Wait.
There's so many supports.
Okay.
Left is healing.
And then deep dive into sea and reach for his swallow.
Activating hide and seek before ejecting the sw... What the fuck?
Oh, I can spit enemies.
Wait.
Oh, I can save people.
I can like... I can like...
Okay.
I can also... Okay.
The bad thing about this guy is that you can definitely grief your team.
You take your teammates and then like spit them off.
He's basically Symmetra.
But worse, because I don't think they can...
I don't think you can like leave his mouth.
So you can grief really hard.
I was just thinking you can eat people off the map.
Jeff can heal while submerged and gain a wall crawl.
Okay.
And then healing spit bubble that heals the allies who collect.
Granting them a healing boost and a movement boost while also launching up nearby enemies.
Okay.
So like what does the bubble do if I hit him?
Oh.
Wait.
That's...
Pick my bubble!
Pick it up!
Reduces damage taken.
Oh.
So he can't get critical hit.
And then there's team up with...
Can ride on Groot's shoulder.
Oh, I can ride on Groot's shoulder for this.
I guess he can...
Oh, it's like Raccoon and Groot.
Okay.
Alright.
So we got that page done.
What else is new?
Moon Knight is the new one too.
I heard there's like a lot of DPS too.
So many healers, but Loki is still our favorite.
Pudge top!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The only...
The only thing that sucks about the Loki during beta test got like hella nerfed.
So like, I don't know if he's good again because like they nerfed Loki so hard.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm downloading Rivals right now and hope you have fun playing as well.
Yeah, I'm so excited to try out the new characters.
I'm really excited to try out the new characters for the launch itself.
They revealed so many!
I was not expecting them to reveal so many at once on launch date because that means there's gonna because like, you know, every other game would take a while like releasing new characters every couple of months.
So that means they're gonna be adding more to this game later.
Because they're not stopping.
Also, I saw like it's basically Batman.
Yeah, there's grappling hook.
There's the night glider.
There's...
Okay, there's a knockdown.
There's a rising leaps.
I guess that's like double jump too.
It's Batman but like Marvel Rivals.
No, Doki!
You can't say that!
Batman but like with actual powers instead of money.
Wait, did I miss Hawkeye?
Sorry, everybody always forgets about Hawkeye.
I mean, it looks pretty cool.
Oh, look!
There's Clint!
There's a... what's his name?
The guy in the event.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's his name?
What's the actor?
Jeremy Renner!
Jeremy Renner Hawkeye!
Oh my god, they added Jeremy Renner Hawkeye!
Let's freaking go!
Let's see.
Okay, so I heard if you have your crosshair on the head, it's even stronger.
Shoot three explosive, hunter sight.
That's the Shiva Katana.
Shoot a hypersonic, dealing two instances of damage to enemies and pathfinding, flicking them.
White Batman, my beloved!
Frango, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Alright, let's see.
Ronan Slash?
Wait, Ronan Slash?
Yeah, he's Clint Barton.
Why is it Ronan?
Is this sword from...
Wait, I thought he's from New York.
I...
Wait, okay, I'm a little confused.
Is that part of the lore?
Is that his other name?
I was like, I thought he was...
Oh, he was a Ronan for a while?
I didn't know that!
I thought he was...
He had a weeb face?
I didn't know that!
I thought he, like, lived in New York!
Oh my god!
I didn't know he became a Ronan for a little bit.
I was a little confused.
I was like, Ronan Slash?
What?
No.
I stopped watching Avengers because I realized that Marvel movies are all the same at one point.
So I stopped.
I never saw her abilities though.
I like how she's like, the easiest character to play.
She's the easiest character to play, but like, she's apparently the strongest Marvel hero.
Rocket upwards with bounce of her tail.
Reloads squirrel blockade.
Imprisoning the first...
Oh my god, you can trap them with your squirrels?
Wait, oh!
Wait, that's fucking...
That's hardcore, bro.
Thor.
Oh, we did Thor!
That's Thor, Winter Soldier, and Wolverine.
Oh my god, Thor is back.
Okay.
Miramar's Bash.
God of Thunder.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many.
I assume these two are also...
Yeah, that... Okay, that's a tank.
He's a DPS.
He has to be.
Alright, let's see.
Is he just Reaper?
Leap hide in Dash 4 and slam down with Bionic Arm, dealing damage to enemies.
Dash 4, seizing enemies along the path and launch up enemies in front to end of the dash.
His gun seems like a shotgun.
Charge up and launch a powerful electric punch with Bionic Arms, but with range.
Charge up and launch a hook with Bionic Reeling.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's scary.
Wait, he's Doomfist.
Oh no.
He's Doomfist with a shotgun.
Does he really need a shotgun?
He has...
He has a Roadhog hook and...
Oh my god, he has a Roadhog.
DPS Doom is back, baby.
Doomfist with a gun.
That's actually...
And a Roadhog hook.
That's scary as fuck.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
The scariest things about Doomfist mains is that they are not...
They're not afraid to like grind hundreds of hours trying to figure out every single rollout you can on one map.
Like, that's what I'm scared of.
I'm scared of the Winter Soldier rollouts.
Savage Claw.
Good lord, why is he so wide?
Wait, do we not have Mr. Fantastic yet?
Is he not here yet?
No, he's not part of the initial launch?
No!
Wait, there's DPS too.
There's so many melee characters now.
I feel like a lot of them...
A lot of the melee...
A lot of the newer release characters are mostly melee.
So that's a little scary.
That's actually... Oh, no Mr. Fantastic.
I know.
I'm so sad.
Okay, so I can regenerate healing.
So this is basically he doesn't have to worry about heals.
Alright, it's time.
Oh yeah, guys, I forgot.
I need to check my settings.
Guys, I forgot.
I don't even... Oh my god.
Not windowed, that's for sure.
Alright, let's see.
Quality...
I need to know if like...
uh... high graphics.
Okay, medium.
We'll do medium.
I'm not really into the whole...
I don't know if it... I don't know if it transfers over.
That's the thing.
It might not transfer over.
So, we'll see.
Push to talk.
Mic volume, voice chat, yes.
Yeah, we'll get the subtitles too.
I want to know what they're talking about.
Uh, keyboard.
Oh, is that default?
That's default.
Guys, what were my settings?
Oh!
No!
Guys, give me a sec.
It didn't transfer over?
Are you serious?
No!
Oh my God.
Okay, guys, I'm sorry.
I have to...
Oh my God.
I'm so sad.
It doesn't transfer over.
I have to figure this out.
I thought it... Guys, tell me what my...
Guys, I need a note.
What is my...
What is...
What is my fucking sense, guys?
That's the only thing I need to figure out.
Everything else I'm fine with.
Okay.
We'll do a dot.
Actually, I'm good with either.
I'm good with crosshair and dot.
We'll do crosshair just so... I don't know.
I feel like crosshair today.
Outline details, blur details, cross... How do I make it so it doesn't fucking rotate?
Uh... No animation.
There you go.
No animation.
Okay, we got...
Get that down.
Uh... Lampacity, blur, center gap.
There you go.
And then length.
Get that smaller.
Alright, there we go.
I should be fine.
1.09?
Okay.
1.09.
I can't believe it didn't transfer over.
You assume it does.
Cause like, I basically kept everything the same.
WASD, jump, melee.
Okay, that.
And then...
Melee, it's inbounded.
And then push to talk.
UI, communication, ping.
Number of attacks.
Sorry, I'm getting a little serious right now.
Because I'm going into Overwatch mode.
I'm going...
Uh...
Let's see.
That should be good.
I'm going to like, serious mode right now when I do all that.
Alright!
I think we're okay now.
We don't need tutorial.
We basically played this game like three times already.
Wait.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm going... I'm feeling a little sweaty right now.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, there's so many...
Oh my God, look at that.
Oh my God, there's...
Look at... This is all the DPS.
Holy shit.
Okay, I want to try.
Let's try Scroll Girl.
Let's try.
I heard... Apparently I was talking to Surefour about it.
And then...
Because like, he was like talking about people were complaining that like there were too many DPS characters.
And then the devs responded back and was like, yeah, because we want DPS to be able to kill things.
They were like, yeah, because we're trying to make sure people who play DPS actually have fun and can actually kill things.
So...
Let's see.
Whoa.
Is it 1.09?
Is that actually my sense?
I can't tell.
Okay, there's the...
Where is that seed going?
Okay.
And then...
Oh, I got the team up.
Nice.
Whee!
What does my E do?
I already forgot.
Oh, no!
I don't remember what my E does!
Oh, no.
Is she Junkrat?
I don't like him or... Oh, wait.
Unless... Oh, shit!
Okay.
Wait, actually, I might like her.
She's so easy!
I literally just throw this around.
There we go.
Alright, easy.
I just throw these around until people die.
I don't want this!
She's so fucking easy.
Holy shit!
I just take the angles and that's it.
Fucking easiest game of my life.
Honestly.
Let me just stay there.
Nice.
Goodbye, guys.
Take the angle.
And now I can do this.
Pew!
Alright, let's go!
You know what?
Fucking go, squirrel!
Go!
Who fucking cares?
Oh, my God.
That was the easiest fucking game of my life.
November is over.
You're right.
It's nutting time.
Go in.
Go in, squirrel girl!
Just spawn cap them.
Take this angle.
Never have to move again.
Never.
Just stay there for the rest of your life.
Just keep staying there.
Alright, let's go!
Non-stop nutting!
Oh, my God.
This is so fucking cringe.
Holy shit.
Yeah, that's right!
Keep going at it!
Oh, shit.
I'm so sorry.
Or am I?
Alright.
Boom.
I don't even have to aim.
I'm just throwing as many nuts as I can.
I'm not even aiming anymore.
Like, I'm just putting in a general range and it's working.
God, I love squirrel girl.
Actually, easiest game of my life.
Let's go.
Yeah, squirrel girl!
Let's go!
No wonder she's like one star.
Holy fuck.
I've now realized why she's one star, guys.
Oh, they're playing squirrel girl!
Oh, yeah!
There can only be one squirrel girl.
That's fucking right.
How dare you.
How fucking dare you.
There can only be...
Oh, no.
He ate.
Wait, I saw him fucking...
Nom, nom, nom.
Okay, that's fine.
We got him.
There's only you, Captain America.
They're all dead.
Captain America, I don't think anybody's gonna be assembling.
How am I...
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
There can only be one nutter.
How much...
I'm not even gonna wash.
I'm not...
Wait, I'm still hitting them.
Alright.
Boom.
And then, more nuts.
That's right.
Keep nutting.
Oh, my God.
There's so many tanks now.
Keep nutting.
You've got this, squirrel girl.
Just keep nutting.
They'll die eventually.
They have a learning problem.
Just keep nutting.
Throw all the squirrels out.
There's nobody here.
It's okay.
Goodbye, tsunami.
Goodbye.
The enemy has, like, zero kills.
I don't think they know what they're doing.
Like...
I'm literally just taking high ground here.
And then...
And then, just nut.
Like, look at this poor guy.
Up top there.
Like...
You know what?
Great first game.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, shit.
It's alright.
We got Bruce Banner out of his D.Va mech.
That's fine.
There you go.
Easy.
What a great first game.
I knew picking this character wasn't the right thing to do.
I don't think I've, like, moved at all.
Like, I honestly don't think I have moved.
I'm just, like, hoping I hit something, and I do.
Oh, shit!
Oh, wait!
People are dying!
That's fine.
I have this angle.
That's okay.
I can clutch this.
I just keep shooting this angle.
I might hit something.
As long as I'm here, I'll hit something.
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, tsunami time!
Go, squirrels, go!
Go, squirrels!
Just keep hitting!
Oh, they're all stuck!
They're all stuck!
Interaction game.
I am doing my best here.
Alright, guys.
Party's still alive.
Like, I'm literally farming damage.
I'm just farming damage on them.
Okay, nice.
Get him out of his mech suit.
Get boost battery out of his mech.
Wow, that was...
That's just...
Oh, it only works if you hit him.
Is this an idle clicker?
What did Loki do?
Holy shit!
Okay, I had the most...
What did Loki...
How is he MVP?
Look at my damage!
I literally just spammed the corner!
Guys!
What the...
How the fuck...
Oh my god, I literally just...
I literally was just in that corner and it never left.
Easiest 12k of my life.
Yeah, because he just needs to aim!
I did so much...
I did so much damage!
I was just nutting in the corner.
Just keep throwing nuts!
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's try another DPS character.
Okay.
You know what?
Let's try...
Oh my god, we got walls now!
Okay, I should read.
Oh my god, wait.
Where's her ability?
Okay.
Baton.
Dash forward.
Unleash a spinning kick to launch enemies.
Switch to...
Okay, we got snipe.
This is all melee.
Her ability is mostly melee.
Alright, from 1 star to like 4 star.
It shouldn't be that difficult.
I think I might have got MMR adjusted already.
Maybe.
Oh shit!
We have Nut Girl!
Oh my god, I can run!
Guys, it's okay.
What was the C again?
Guys, what was...
I might have forgot what C does.
Guys...
Oh my god, we have Nut Girl.
It's already GG's.
I don't know, but keep jumping!
Okay, but I need to know what does C do.
Oh god.
Oh shit!
Oh shit, not magic!
Oh my god, I'm scared!
Okay, there we go.
Oh, come on.
You can't do that forever.
What?
Holy shit though!
Her damage is insane!
Her damage is actually crazy.
I'm gonna admit.
Her damage is so fucking insane.
Like, that was a tank by the way.
I shot Doctor Strange and he's supposed to be a fucking tank.
Oh fuck!
No!
Oh no, not the cloak man.
Oh no!
No, not cloak man!
Oh my god, wait, is it...
Wait, was C walls?
I forgot.
I forgot that one is...
Melee.
I didn't remember that I have melee.
Okay, I have melee guys.
Alright.
I just gotta hit my shots.
I need to get used to like...
Oh god, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, I'm getting used to the aim guys!
I'm getting used to the aim guys!
It's getting better!
Oh fuck!
Oh no!
No!
No, please!
Venom!
No!
Do we not have healers?
Guys, I think it's because we don't have healers guys.
I think it's because we don't have healers.
It's not me!
We literally have zero healers!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please!
I have no healers!
That's fine!
I got him away from me, right?
No I don't!
No!
Oh my god, please!
Somebody also heal!
Okay, I will...
I am a person that's willing to heal for the team.
I'm actually willing to be a team player.
What the fuck?
How are you letting him do that?
Just fucking...
Just hit him!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Now I'll swap to healer.
Okay, how do I play him?
I'm just saying it's not me, it's my team.
I am willing to be a team player, guys.
Get the bubble!
There's so many bubbles!
Get it!
Oh my god, get the bubble!
Please!
Just get the bubble!
I'm big of you!
There's so many bubbles!
Oh my god.
Please, I'm blowing so many bubbles, what do you want from me?
All I do is blow bubbles!
That's all I do!
Bro, you're fucking trash.
You're actually trash.
Just take the bubble!
Just take it!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
Bubble, bubble, bubble!
Just grab it!
Oh shit!
Get it!
Oh my god, he solo ulted me!
He sharked me back!
He actually sharked me back!
Okay, I'm coming back.
Guys, I can shark him too!
Grab it!
Okay, don't worry, I got you!
Bubble, bubble!
Okay.
That's fucking right.
That's right, I'm leaving!
Goodbye!
Bubble, bubble, bubble!
There we go.
Spit!
Alright.
Oh my god, bro, I hate this guy.
I actually hate him so much.
That's fucking right!
You can't do shit!
I have 20 bubbles here!
What you gonna do?
I have infinite bubbles!
Okay, I can literally just spit here.
There we go.
It's fine.
I'm better.
Oh no!
Oh my god, they took my friends!
Okay, that's fine.
Get over here, Scarlet!
Oh no.
It's okay.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Pew, pew, pew!
Pew, pew!
Oh!
Okay, I think our venom might be...
Where did it all go?
Okay.
Don't worry, guys, you got...
Guys, push him!
Okay, I...
I'm just saying that it wasn't me.
For sure, I...
I'm literally MVP!
Wait, I'm not.
That's the enemy lip.
What?
That's the enemy?
Oh yeah, he did 12k healing.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, that's me!
Oh, I'm SVP!
That's even worse!
I'm actually my team's MVP!
What the fuck, guys?
I swapped to a healer and I'm still...
I'm...
I still have more damage?
Okay, now I know it's not me.
Now I know.
Now I definitely know it's not me.
Okay, C is the walls.
Now I know.
Cause I thought it's like I have to wait until Hawkeye...
I thought that Hawkeye has to ult and then I get walls.
But apparently...
I have ability walls.
Which is pretty crazy.
I feel like that's like really broken.
Okay, Hawkeye.
Okay, what do I do for Hawkeye?
Shoot a powerful arrow.
Shoot three explosive arrows.
Capture afterimages of enemies.
Unsheathe a katana and slash forward.
Shoot a hypersonic arrow, dealing two instances of damage to enemy's path, inflicting slow.
Oh fuck, I didn't get a chance to read everything.
I...
Oh my god, I got overwhelmed.
Okay.
I can still read it.
Okay, I can double jump and I can swing a katana.
Alright.
Increase focus.
Okay, dealing two damage.
Okay, that's slow.
And the ship is...
I can... Okay, that's fine.
I most likely will not change...
Uh...
Most likely I might not change...
Okay.
I might not change the...
changed explosives.
Cause I feel like... I don't know.
I feel like normal is better.
I guess explosive, I have like a limit for it.
Okay.
We'll see how this goes.
Do we have healers?
Guys, I don't see a healer with us.
Guys.
Oh, we have rocket.
Okay, that's good.
We have rocket.
That's fine.
We have rocket, right?
That's okay.
Guys.
Is our tank tanking?
That's what I wanna know.
I wanna know.
Guys, how come they get a shield?
That's so cool.
I wish we had that too.
Hey, Captain America.
Do you maybe shield us a little better?
You know?
Nice.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
I might change my crosshair.
I don't like the...
I think I might just go with the dot crosshair.
I don't like...
Not a big fan of just that.
I don't know.
That's just my opinion.
Not a huge fan of it.
Okay.
Oh, she's slow.
She's slow.
Okay.
I'll get the explosives though.
Oh, okay.
It's not charged.
Okay, so there's like a low range for that.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
Come on.
Peek me.
That's fucking right, bitch!
That's right!
Oh!
Alright, this is pretty easy.
Okay, I'm gonna take high ground then.
I think I can take high ground.
Oh my god, there's Spider-Man.
Oh no, Spider-Man.
Okay, I can do this then.
Since...
Alright.
Oh my god!
He's jumping everywhere he goes!
He knows!
It's too fast!
Alright, walls!
Wait, what?
Oh my god, what's the use of walls when...
Okay, this clutters my screen.
Okay!
Guys, I don't think I like walls.
I don't think I like it at all.
The walls is so...
It's a little bit too much.
That's for sure.
Oh no!
Please!
Please, I'm just a little guy!
It's not walls!
It's not walls at all!
Wait, what does it do?
Okay, damage.
Okay, I just gotta hit the afterimage.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I need to hit the afterimage.
I need to change my crosshair.
I do not like the...
I need to... This is the first time I've done, like, dot and the crosshair.
And the cross.
Not a big fan!
Not gonna lie.
Not a big fan of that.
I keep thinking I'm using shift.
Oh no.
Okay, I need to jump up.
Where's my double jump?
Please.
Oh, nice.
Double jump's a cooldown because my legs get tired.
My legs get tired.
You should be tired now.
Get him out of mech!
Nice, we got him out of mech!
He's so low, guys!
Guys, there's a storm here too!
Okay.
That's fine.
We're gonna use explosive here.
I think explosives is, like, you gotta be close range for it.
For sure.
Okay.
Maybe I'll hit... oh no, not him again!
Oh my god, she's gonna clap!
Clap!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's not good.
That's right.
Oh, yes!
Oh, thank god!
Please heal me!
Please!
I'm carrying!
I'm literally literally carrying!
Please!
I need heals!
I'm in front of you!
Okay, this ult is actually crazy.
I figured out how to use it.
Oh my god, please!
No way!
I almost killed him!
But they actually have healers!
Stop it!
They actually have healers!
She's like, what do I do?
That's not fair!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
We got him out of mech.
He's out of mech now.
Alright.
I can literally be in this corner.
Nice load.
Oh my god, I wish we had shields like that.
We don't care about accuracy here.
We just gotta...
Oh god, he's hulking out though.
We're just logging.
You know, we appreciate the effort though.
But maybe don't stand in front of a sniper.
Like, that's not it.
That's not it.
Literally, don't stand in front of me.
We don't need to worry about accuracy, we just need them to like...
Oh shit.
There we go.
Wait, they blocked it?
Jesus Christ.
Nice, we got him.
Oh shit.
Oh, don't worry!
I got you!
Yes!
That's fucking right.
Wait, he's so tiny.
His hitbox is literally like a D.Va D.Va mech head.
Oh shit.
That's fine, we're gonna wait for them to come over so I can use this.
That's fucking right.
Use the afterimage.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Please!
Dance for me!
No!
Oh my god!
No dancing!
Okay, I need to swap my crosshair, I hate it.
No, I can't swap my crosshair!
No!
They're gonna...
They're actually gonna cap this!
I die and they cap!
That's so fucked.
This always happens.
That's when you know I'm the carry guys.
I say as I literally just missed all my shots.
All I'm saying, I was definitely the carry here.
I died and then I had to...
Okay.
I think I can see them here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He's gonna start smashing!
No!
Please!
He's coming for me!
I'm gonna be squishy!
No!
Captain America!
Why did you take it from me?
You could have took it from me!
Oh my god!
I need to change my reticle!
Okay.
We're gonna go with Dot.
I'm gonna try Dot out.
I'm just a human!
That's like the worst part.
I'm not even like...
It's not like I'm like a special god or anything.
I'm literally just a regular guy.
Trying with a bow.
Like what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
We got bubbles now.
Oh my god, but they got bubbles too.
Oh no!
Not the tsunami!
Okay.
Oh god.
I'm on the afterimage!
Please!
Why is nobody on it?
Oh my god!
Of course the healer I'm just gonna... This wasn't me.
I did so much damage, man.
There's no way.
Like, like I literally...
If you combine three of my teammates' damage I'm...
Oh my god.
I'm 12k!
Like...
All I did was just... I just shot!
I just kept shooting!
I kept shooting!
It's not my fault.
It's definitely not my fault.
I actually tried so hard.
I tried so hard.
My team.
I'm just...
I'm just weighted down by my team.
Spamming the tank.
Shake my head.
I can't believe she said she's carry when all she did was spam.
No!
No, that is not true.
That is not true.
I did so much damage.
Okay, Hela's been fun though.
I like Hela.
I think Hela's actually one of the strongest characters.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna...
Maybe I should do like...
Maybe... I don't know.
I'm trying to figure out what kind of crosshair I want to use.
Maybe I'll do that and then we'll...
Maybe I could do this.
Okay, nope.
Where is the outline, outline, center gap, crosshair angle?
Where's the reticle?
Uh...
Where's the dot?
I'm trying to get rid of the dot.
Details, dot.
Okay, there you go.
Maybe I'll try getting rid of the dot, maybe?
I don't want to use the... Okay, circle and crosshair.
Where the fuck?
How do I get rid of the dot?
Dot crosshair.
Center gap, 26.
Oh no.
Oh no, please.
I'm trying to get rid of the dot.
No!
Where's the dot?
What?
Oh my god, where is it?
I want to get rid of the dot.
I'm sorry.
I'll be there soon.
Reticle path.
Oh, there you go.
Dot, there you go.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm heading over.
Oh wait, this is a new map.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my teammates are dead.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Okay, me dying should not mean like my entire team is just gone.
Like, how?
There's...
Actually, how?
How did my entire team just die like that?
Like, how did they all...
I was not here for like one...
Okay, maybe not one second.
Maybe like six seconds.
But still.
Okay, I don't like this crosshair.
This is way too like wide.
So I'm gonna...
Give me a swap.
Oh, I feel like a gamer already where I'm just swapping crosshairs all the time.
Yeah, this crosshair ain't it for me.
I'm not a fan of this crosshair.
Alright.
Do we have healers?
Why is our healer like in the fucking...
Oh, my god.
I can't see.
I...
I actually...
It's too wide.
I might need a dot crosshair.
Oh, my god.
I'm trying my best.
I've been in 75 HP for the longest time.
Oh, my god.
This is what it's like to have a tank.
I feel like I've never had a tank that actually like, you know...
Tanks.
I think it's because we actually don't have...
No, we do.
We have a DPS tank.
That's why.
That makes a lot more sense now.
We have a DPS tank.
Okay, yeah.
I can tell why now.
We actually have a DPS tank.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
Okay.
Shark, heal me!
Shark!
It's the only way!
No!
Alright, where's my reticle?
Okay, definitely not this.
Maybe I'll do the dot.
Oh, no.
Where did the dot go?
Okay, dot and then...
Maybe a bigger dot.
There we go.
I'm so sorry.
I pressed the wrong button.
It's all going wrong.
Okay, to be fair, my support is just like DPSing this entire time.
Like, I'm literally like trying to save my team.
Yes, I accidentally pressed Q.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, they're doing it.
They're doing it.
They're doing it!
Sharkboy, please!
You're literally our only healer!
After you keep dying!
Oh my god!
Do I have to play support?
Bro!
When will I get a support?
Guys!
That shouldn't be a thing!
The SBB was gone!
I wasn't even playing the game!
No, you don't understand!
I shouldn't be!
The MVP!
Okay.
Maybe if I do this.
Okay, no.
Okay, I'm trying to figure out my ideal.
Okay, maybe I'll try this.
Alright.
Okay, if it's SBMM, I should like...
If it's SBMM, I should get the benefit of that too.
I shouldn't be the only one that knows how to play the video game.
I don't understand!
Alright.
I guess I'll play a healer.
I guess.
I guess I'll play a healer, because no one else wants to heal.
Alright.
I guess I'll heal.
We'll try Cloak and Dagger.
God, this guy is...
Okay.
Jesus Christ, okay.
I'm trying to like remember how to play two characters at once.
Okay.
Deploy a Veil of Darkness, blinds, enshroud enemies, and grant them phase, making them...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
I'll figure it out.
Okay, I'll do that.
And then, this is damage.
And then this is where I heal.
Okay, and then this damages people.
Okay.
Oh, the cooldowns are different!
Guys.
That's actually crazy.
The cooldowns are different.
So like, if I use up all my cooldowns on Cloak, I get new cooldowns.
Yeah.
I noticed it.
Yeah, so like, if I use up all my cooldowns, I can like swap to the next one, and then it'll be a different cooldown.
Swap!
Heal!
That's right.
It's time to heal, guys.
Okay.
Okay, swap!
Oh my god, this is dumb.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have...
It's a lot of thinking.
That's for sure.
It's...
I'm like trying to think right now.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, and then I just...
I can literally just do like that.
Alright.
THINKING!
Okay.
And then...
Suck!
Oh my god, this is broken.
Because I can track.
Oh my god, should I have healed?
I'm so sorry!
I'm sorry!
I'm getting overwhelmed!
Oh my god!
I need to remember my abilities!
I get so overwhelmed because there's two characters!
Okay.
Okay, that's like a different move.
Okay, there we go.
Get over here!
Oh my god, please heal!
Get healed, please, please, please!
Oh my god!
Oh, I fucked up!
Jesus Christ!
There's too many abilities!
I'm so overwhelmed!
I'm just like, what do I do?
What do I do?
Okay.
I don't have any abilities left, guys!
I don't have any abilities left!
Alright.
Alright,
heal!
Heal!
This is damage, this is heal!
Remember this, Doki!
Doki!
Fight in the orb!
We're invisible now!
Please, please!
Please, how do you die so fast?
I don't understand!
I don't understand how we die so fast!
Please, guys!
I need you guys to be able to do stuff too!
I can't outheal this damage!
I can't heal!
I know, wait.
I know a character that can outheal.
Like, I can't even damage!
Because my team!
My team dies so fast!
The only healer that can outheal this.
It's time to clap!
This is literally the best support character.
Okay, chef is out.
Icedars.
Clumptasty.
The freeze.
Okay, that freezes.
This is literally like...
This is like the biggest healing output character.
I think.
I think it's like her and shark.
I haven't tried Loki yet.
But it's clap to heal.
It's when we start clapping, guys.
We gotta give this flower to...
Our flower to our tank.
Yeah, I think shark also heals a lot.
Because of his bubbles that he spits out.
Because that heals too.
So...
Clap!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Clap.
Please, I'm trying my best to clap as hard as I can.
Please, I swear to god.
Please!
Please, Venom!
We're fucking clapping so hard!
Oh my god, please!
Oh, I'm too...
What?!
What is my team?!
Oh my god!
Guys...
I think...
We're burning three supports?
What am I doing?
I have ult!
How do I have ult already?
We did one fight!
Okay, I'm gonna use my ult and then...
I didn't have to be support.
I could've actually played DPS.
I didn't even realize.
I'm gonna do this and then start fucking ulting.
This is it.
We push in.
We fucking push in.
I'm dancing.
I'm fucking dancing.
We can't die.
I literally have like...
The ultimate heals right now.
We can't die.
Like...
Nobody is supposed to die at this point.
I swear to god.
I swear to god, guys.
Oh my god!
Do I have to do everything?
Okay, here we go.
Just keep healing.
Oh no.
Get back over here.
Oh, hit something!
Hit something!
Clap!
Nice!
I did so much damage there.
Alright, I'm fucking swapping characters.
Goodbye.
I'm done playing support.
Wait, where's the...
Alright, I'm not throwing.
I just don't want to play support anymore.
Alright.
The tank, the DPS, and the healer.
That's right.
My team is starting to win.
I swapped to Widowmaker.
That's right.
I'm her.
I'm him now.
Team starts to win.
It's Widow time.
My team is losing.
Guys, why?
I literally...
Really?
What?
How did... I swapped and he dies?
This is not fair.
We have two healers!
We literally have two healers!
I should be legally allowed to play this character.
Here we go.
That's not fair!
Oh my god, are you serious?
Oh my god, this is not fair.
I literally just got my ult.
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
We have two supports!
How was I supposed to know they couldn't do anything?
Oh my god.
We need three healers to win.
I just wanted to play DPS.
Oh, I swear to god.
I swear to god, if I still have the most healing after everything I did.
Like, after swapping the healer.
I swear.
I actually did.
I actually had the most...
That's so sad.
That's so fucking sad.
I actually had the most healing.
Oh my god.
I stopped clapping and then they lost.
Guys, I...
You know, in SPMM, they're supposed to give me teammates that are also at my level.
But...
Why am I carrying every game?
Why am I...
It doesn't make sense.
Alright.
Marvel Goats is calling Snooks.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Okay, let's see.
I wanna try...
Guys, I just wanted to play Widowmaker.
That's all I want.
I just... Okay, so I'm not playing Widowmaker.
They don't want me to...
You know what?
I'm playing Soldier.
That's it.
I'm mad.
I'm gonna play Soldier 76.
Okay.
Alright, I need to remember the abilities.
Okay, Unleash Gatling Gun, Shift, E that grounds and blocks damage from the front while dealing a smoke grenade.
Okay.
Shotgun.
We're fine.
Alright, nice.
What's this?
Okay.
I just gotta figure this out.
And this is Smoke Bomb.
Alright.
We're fine.
I just can't run.
So we're not as fine as I think we are.
Okay.
Weeee.
Oh shit.
Heavy weapons time.
Go through.
Come on, you know you want to.
That's right.
Suppressing fire.
Suppressing - Oh shit, okay.
It's a little awkward now.
It's a little awkward here.
Guys, don't die, guys.
Oh god.
Oh thank god, he's healing.
He actually is healing me.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
He portal'd!
They have actual healers!
Oh my god!
The melee healers!
Who would've thought?
They actually have healers, guys.
I don't know what that's like.
I don't know what that's like, guys.
I actually don't.
Oh yeah, you do!
Same.
I don't know what that's like.
Honestly.
Oh my god, please!
Please!
How do I find- I need healing.
I need healing.
Where is- I need healing.
Okay, there we go.
I need healing.
Where is it?
How do I- okay.
God damn it.
I need healing.
Okay, we can't do that.
God damn it.
I just need a typical Genji player as a QA.
As a support player?
A bad support?
A bad support actually fucking makes me angry.
You guys don't understand.
Like, when I have to deal with a bad support, it's like...
Hahaha.
Okay.
It just like- it just gives me more- gives me more hate in my life.
Oh my god, I will- I will ult this so that we can win.
Like...
Hahaha.
I actually know how to aim, so...
Okay.
That's fine.
Where does she portal to?
Oh no, please!
No!
Please.
Guys, please.
Just...
Please, I just need a little heal.
I just...
Just a little.
Oh, cause we have no tank.
Are you- do I have to be a team player and play a tank too?
Oh yeah!
I can do that, but like, clearly you guys are fucking...
No!
Oh thank god!
Like, yeah I can be a tank but you guys gotta pick up the fucking slack!
Okay.
Alright.
It's time to be a tank.
Alright, what does Captain America does?
Okay, we'll figure it out while we play him.
Hahaha, I don't know what he does.
But we'll- I have to play them all, apparently.
Alright, this is his run.
This is his run.
Don't worry guys, a tank is here.
Don't worry.
Bro!
Guys, I'm your tank!
Please!
Hahaha!
I'm literally your tank!
Please!
I'm fucking shielding this!
Guys!
Please!
I can't aim!
All I can do is melee, I swear to god!
Literally, that's all I can do!
I can just melee!
Please protect your only tank!
Hahaha!
I swear!
Please!
Just all you need to do is heal me!
I'm your only tank!
Oh my god!
There has to be somebody!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I can't!
How do I keep getting the worst teammates in my fucking life?
Hahaha!
I don't understand!
I don't understand, guys.
Oh my god!
You're right.
I should just play Wolverine.
Yeah, but you can't aim!
Like, I don't...
I don't understand!
Hahaha!
I played support!
I played tank!
I played DPS!
I did it all!
I fucking did it all!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
That means I got all six of my kills!
Okay.
That's okay, I'm calm.
I'm calm now.
I forgot.
I forgot how tilted I could get.
Hahaha!
Fine!
Fine, I'll heal!
I'll fucking heal!
I don't...
Fine!
I'll be the healer, bitch!
I'll fucking... I'll do it!
I'll fucking do it!
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
I forgot what he does.
I...
Fine, I'll do it myself.
I'm the only healer!
I mean...
I'm still the only healer!
Nobody else wants to heal!
Okay.
It's okay, I'm calm.
Um...
Gather quantum energy and collision and swiftly launch it at enemies.
Target an enemy for bouncing, which also heals himself, upon healing.
Self-targets if... Okay.
Alright, we got this.
It's friendship bracelet.
I remember now.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm fucking fine.
Okay.
What is it?
Friendship bracelet.
Okay.
Now we're all friends.
Hahaha!
We're all friends now.
It snapped to heal.
I remember now.
We just gotta keep snapping.
I'll just keep snapping.
If you die, it's because you're fucking stupid, not me.
I'm literally... I literally have to do this myself.
That's fucking right.
Hahaha!
Snap!
That's fucking right!
I shall keep snapping!
Let us all heal now.
Alright.
Thank God.
Yeah, but it's not the same.
I just wanna shoot things.
We just have to do this.
Snap!
Don't worry.
Oh yeah?
You don't want healing?
I'm literally your only healer.
Oh my God, please.
I'm sorry, but...
I have to reload.
Snap!
Keep snapping!
Oh, he's so low though.
Please, he's so low!
Alright, this should be able to hit him.
Oh my God, I swear to God.
I swear... Get over here!
Snap!
I swear to God, please.
Alright.
Okay, that's good.
All he's doing is just pushing for no reason.
Snap!
Alright.
Oh my God, this is so easy.
God, I'm a fucking natural.
But fuck me for wanting to play...
For wanting to be a DPS player for once in my life.
Yeah.
How dare I want to be a fucking DPS player.
How dare I not want to be a goddamn babysitter for once.
Like...
I'm literally...
I'm literally solo healing.
Oh my God, that's so cute.
Wait, there's a tiger there.
There you go.
Let's all have friendship.
We're all soul bonded now.
You know what, fuck this.
If we die, we die.
There you go.
Oh my God, I fucking got swallowed.
No!
Get me out of here!
It's okay, so bye!
Guys, I'm your only support!
That's fine.
I'm your only support, guys.
But that's okay.
That's okay!
It's okay, I am Groot!
Yes, we know!
So fun!
Oh no, not the eye.
That's fine.
Snap!
Guys...
I'm still snapping.
But like...
I need you guys to start killing people.
Because I'm the only support, guys!
Groot, please!
Guys!
Damn!
It's only me and Groot, man.
It's really only me and Groot.
Me and Groot versus the fucking world.
Wait, this is it.
This might be the one time.
Well, I guess he's dead.
Well, I guess he's dead too.
What the fuck was he doing here?
Okay, heal!
I'm sorry, Groot!
Oh, I'm so sorry!
There was no way!
There was no fucking way!
There was four people!
I keep thinking my left click can heal.
But it's literally just damage.
Like, I keep forgetting that.
Alright, go in!
Go in!
This is it!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I need to remember.
Left click is literally just DPS.
Alright, I'm gonna get out of here now.
Alright, goodbye!
Oh, no.
Oh, please!
I can't!
Please!
Groot, no!
Snap!
Oh my god!
Finally!
The ult is a mercy rez.
That's what it is.
Oh my god, thank god!
We did it!
We won our first game!
That's our second game!
That's the solo healer!
To be fair, Groot was actually really good.
That guy was insane.
I just gotta be a god damn heal bot.
It's gotta be a heal bot.
The only fucking heal bot in this team.
The only team, guys, that actually cares.
In a quick play lobby.
Decent teammates?
No, it was literally Groot.
It was...
Groot fucking solo hand carried this.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Guys, can I finally play DPS?
Let's find out.
Let's find out, guys.
Oh, that's a support?
That's a support?
Does this mean...
Oh, Sir Roland!
Sir Roland, you know what would be great for the team?
If, you know...
Sir Roland!
Oh, DPS?
Yeah, that.
Yeah, sure.
Sure.
Yeah, 100% this game needs roll queue.
Guys.
Wouldn't it be great if we have...
a second support?
That would be...
Guys, I heard this new concept where people would play two supports, two tanks.
We don't even need two tanks.
People would just play two supports.
It's a wild concept.
I just recently heard about it too.
I heard it was one of the ways to win video games.
Having two healers.
It's like an actual real life cheat.
The devs can't do anything about it.
The devs can't ban it or anything.
I fucked up.
Whoops.
I fucked up a little bit.
Okay.
Come on!
No!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, please!
I did like damage, but like I...
I did so much...
No, I did so much damage, but like...
Oh my god, we have two healers!
Oh my god, it worked!
It worked, guys!
We actually have two healers!
Holy shit!
Who would've thought?
They actually...
They know the strats.
They know the legal strats.
Oh my god, that's actually crazy.
That's actually crazy that they know the practice.
It's like it's almost cheating.
It might as well be cheating.
My god.
I wonder what it's like to have healers.
I wonder.
I wonder what it's like.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh.
I learned.
Guys, I figured out what that actually...
how to use that now.
I fucked it up.
I actually fucked that up.
That's crazy.
I forgot to hit the ground.
I don't know if you know this, but when you have your ult, you have to hit the fucking floor with it.
I did not hit the floor.
Okay.
Okay, this is not fair!
They actually get kills!
Oh my god.
Like he's getting healed!
What do I do when they get fucking healed?!
Like what?!
Oh my god!
I would get him one!
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I can actually kill people when they stop getting healed.
Who would have thought?!
What a fucking insane concept!
Insane!
Fucking concept chat!
I can actually do things in this lobby.
Oh my god, the fucking Hulk is actually blocking me.
Like, I can't even get him out of mech.
I think this is where I die.
I think this is where I die, guys.
Guys, I can't get out of here!
Please!
Damn!
I don't know!
I don't make it!
I've tried so hard!
But like, it's actually crazy.
They have this thing called healers and like, I don't know what to do.
Like, I don't know what to do.
Like...
I don't know what to do when they have supports.
Please!
I'll fucking beat you up!
I don't care!
Oh my god, please.
I need just one little heal.
Please!
I just...
I can't!
We only have one support again, guys!
We only have one support!
I think our team is actually...
Oh my god.
I think our team is actually allergic to healers.
Why can't I have that?
Did you see that?
Her HP just comes back!
Her HP comes back!
I don't know what that's like!
I don't know!
What is that like?
Somebody please enlighten me!
Okay.
How do I use this?
Oh!
That's how.
This is fine.
This is fucking fine.
I was trying to figure out how to use that ult.
Get him out of mech.
Just get him out of mech.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god, team.
I'm so happy for you.
That looks like a lot of people that might die.
What?
He flew over me?
Did he actually?
What?
I didn't realize he flew over me.
Oh my god.
Wait, my team's actually trying again.
I'm so proud of them.
I'm actually so happy.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but he's up here.
What is that like?
What is that like to be fully healed?
JK.
Get fucked.
Get shit on.
I'm a better sniper.
But I need medkits.
I need medkits.
What is that like?
I don't know what that's like, having actual supports.
Oh, come on.
That should've been a kill.
Oh no, I'm scared for my team.
Oh no.
Wait, they're winning.
They're winning this.
I believe.
Oh god.
Okay, I stopped believing.
I stopped believing.
Guys, guys, I'm backing out.
Thank you.
Clap, clap.
Keep clapping.
Okay, I'm gonna save my ult for the last fight.
Keep backing out.
Oh god, I missed the jump.
No.
Just keep backing out.
We can do this, guys.
I have ult.
Oh my god.
There we
go.
Oh my god.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Oh, come on.
She's so low.
I have melee.
Oh, this is stupid.
Oh, I'm fucking running.
Clap.
Just keep clapping.
Oh god, just keep clapping.
Oh my god, please.
Please, just keep clapping.
I
do.
Oh my god.
Bro, I can't.
How could a clapping fail?
How did clapping fail?
I don't understand.
We should have clapped harder.
Did you not...
Did she not clap hard enough for me?
I was...
I was better than the enemy Widow.
The enemy Widow kept getting pocketed so fucking hard.
It was bullshit.
Every time I shot her, she just gets healed up.
And then I have to go downstairs to a heal pack.
Like, what the fuck is this bullshit?
Like, actually...
I can't have a fucking...
Okay, I'm calm.
I'm calm.
I'm so fucking calm.
Okay, stealth mode.
Dash forward and slice through enemies along the path with...
Wait, I'll try this out.
If you see...
I take a shot and then she's back to full health.
I'm calm.
Okay, let's see.
What is this ability?
Okay.
How do I do this?
And there's this movement boost and then dash.
Oh, I can pull it back!
I see.
Okay.
It's Genji time.
Alright, this is a projectile I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Imma get... yeah.
Alright, let's see how this goes.
Oh, that's so cute!
It's like a plushy Incredible Hulk.
Okay, let's see how this goes.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I pressed shift!
For some reason, I thought shift was run...
I don't know.
There's so many heroes.
My memory is like...
Fucking up.
Whoops!
I actually dashed right into them.
Oh my god.
He can heal.
Can he sing too?
Yeah, my muscle memory...
Because every time I see shift, I feel like it's not like attack.
It's not like shift into them.
But it's like Genji.
Because I play a lot of support so for me...
Like right now.
I don't play Genji so my muscle memory for shift is mostly used for like...
Not these types of abilities.
Oh my god, he's so low.
That's the worst part.
Can you remember?
Oh my god.
Can you remember not to...
Really?
I'm...
Okay!
Yay!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, please.
Thank you.
Oh, this is so team reliant though.
Oh, where's our tank?
Do we have a tank?
Wait, guys.
Guys.
The question is, do we have a tank?
Guys, we have Venom.
Okay, that's good.
We have Venom.
At least we have Venom.
What was my Q?
I don't know what my Q does.
Guys, I didn't read for my Q.
Oh, what did I do?
What did I do?
I don't even know what I just did.
Oh my god.
I can him.
He's really bad.
I know who I can kill.
I know who's actually bad.
Come on.
Stop!
Stop parkouring!
Oh my god.
Okay, I can farm the fucking Starlord.
But I need the other guy to fucking stop.
He needs to stop parkouring.
I'm too tired for this shit.
Okay.
The Groot is actually...
It's so annoying.
I can dash.
Wait, I could have done that this entire time.
Okay, now I know.
Okay.
No!
That's what it was!
That's what the ult was!
Okay, now I know.
Oh, blue Venom.
Wait, he already has cosmetics?
That's crazy.
I never read.
That's my problem.
I read, but I read like one sentence.
And I'll be like, I understand now.
I feel like sometimes my...
I'll be like, I understand.
I read one sentence.
Okay.
I can ult this.
Oh, I don't know if I should.
I'll wait until we get a safer ult.
Like right here.
Because I think my team needs it.
Oh my god!
Did we not kill anybody?
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's fine.
We got one kill though.
It's okay, we got one kill.
That's all that matters, right?
I'm trying.
I'm hitting as much as I can.
I have not stopped pressing...
Oh shit.
I haven't stopped pressing left click.
I fucking haven't.
What should I do?
Okay, maybe I should play different.
Maybe I should.
I need to suppress fire.
Suppressing fire time.
I don't know if I like psionic.
This time.
That's fine.
I suppressed fire.
Burrrrrrrrrrrrrr.
Wow!
Wow
Wow Oh shit, i'm, sorry, i'm, sorry get me out get me out I really wanted to kill him.
I couldn't help it No, I knew what my hero was.
I think like I need to be closer for Psylocke, I think I got a little greedy.
No, I definitely did I really really wanted to kill him.
You guys don't understand
You guys didn't Can I do this like Like in front of all of them
I think I think it's like It's Psylocke.
You have to be like super um I think Psylocke gotta be like close range for it.
I think that's why I couldn't
It's fine, this is like the tank shredder which i'm what I didn't see Psylocke I didn't see her No I could have killed all of them Oh, she's basically melee, okay, I couldn't tell because she has like the I couldn't tell if she was melee Because she's like she has like the range So I didn't know that's like not range Basically No,
no Yeah, she's definitely close range Now I know okay now that we're close range it's time now that I know how to play her I know now I swear to god.
I swear to god.
I know now We can do this
Oh my god, I can't i'm too squishy never I can't i'm way too squishy
Oh my god instantly dies, okay now I know Psylocke's not for me Psylocke is definitely not for me Oh, no, you know what I Like I don't know Maybe Just need to get into a new queue Like maybe I just need a new queue system Am I level 10 yet?
Please.
I just want to get me out of this hell get me out of This
hell Yeah, I know the opposing team definitely had better teamwork, how am I top exactly
Oh my god, I think to be fair the moment I played like Oh my god, do we have healers?
We do Okay, i'll be a tank.
I don't know what i'm doing, but i'll be a tank Okay, this is him floating Oh wait nice Okay, nice I told definitely know what i'm doing Don't worry guys get behind me Get behind me everybody Oh my god I know what it's like to have a shitty tank.
So get behind me I know what it's like Guys oh my god, that's fucking right I feel your pain We understand you Don't worry I'm worrying a little bit though.
I'm worrying a little bit.
Uh Get behind the shield What the fuck what are you doing?
The pain Don't worry everybody Oh I can do that too.
That's fucking right I can do that too That's fucking right you thought you were special Shield time guys, i'm a little scared.
I hope I am shielding people because I can't see anything
Oh my god get behind me
I just got here
Oh my god, I didn't I got pushed off No, jk.
I didn't get pushed off.
I walked off.
I forgot we were attacking.
I literally just got here I thought we were defending I legitimately thought we were defending I like got here i'm like is this defense?
Is this?
But we were actually We were attacking please get me out of this hellhole.
I want to go to rank I really I get me out get me out.
I need to be in rank.
Let me free.
Let me go
I almost flipped it though.
I did I did almost flipped it I did I chose a tank and then And then we almost made it.
All right We'll see how that we'll see how much he's changed You use rune stones to create a magical field that provides healing over time Uh and use all their okay swap with the selected illusion projected illusion pull out a dagger and stab Uh become invisible.
Okay I I remember i'll play him I don't
Actually have people want to play healer what is this world i'm living in Oh my god, we have people that actually wants to heal.
Oh my god.
I'm living in a fucking dreamland
That's crazy That's actually crazy i'm living in a world where people actually want to heal Wait, okay.
I want to play I'll do Hawkeye again Cloak and dagger is actually cool It's fine.
We don't need a tank I don't like how his like double jump is a cool down.
It's like my legs just got tired Clint just got fucking tired
All right, where are they
Nice Okay, I feel like I should move away um You don't know i'm here, right?
Okay, they don't know Oh my god Oh my god, he's so fast But he's one Wait, he gets regen.
Oh my god forgot.
He's one.
He's one nice Okay, i'll do sonic here I think that helps them
Oh I love Hanzo.
Sorry Hawkeye
Eventually I hit somebody
Nice Look at that My feet This is so dumb, this is actually so dumb.
I literally just gotta do this.
Oh shit.
It's coming over
Oh no, oh no, you think he knows you think he knows
Oh, that's you okay, I thought he was a bad guy Bro he's so low No
Oh Thank you, I am ready to put on a show Oh my god, I don't know how You need to stop that vehicle.
Wait, they got it.
No
Oh no, oh fuck
Oh, he was actually healing Oh my god, that's crazy I actually got healed I don't I don't know how that felt like I didn't realize that was a thing I didn't realize I couldn't tell I lived in like a really fucked up.
Wait, how do I get it?
Oh my god, I need to get a cool down.
I don't know how to get out of here I Where am I?
like I don't know how to walk through this map.
Wait, my sword is a parry.
Wait, that's so fucking cool There you go, you're welcome
Okay What the fuck does the moon do oh my god, I wish I could figure out what it does Okay All right I'm trying my best guys.
Oh, we gotta run.
We gotta run.
We gotta run Oh no, please don't leave me please dance near me i really appreciate it you can dance near me Thank you Keep dancing near me, please Oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry for making you dance near me Okay, it's time you know what this means it's dps it's call of duty time All right,
don't worry guys What one thing I definitely know how to do Is tracking.
Oh my god.
I'm, so sorry everybody I won't troll this time I wanted to play hanzo for one moment of my life, but I promise i'll stop trolling for real
Oh, thank god, oh, thank god.
All right, i'm ready
Oh my god get over there get over there I am ready.
Oh, no, he starts dancing.
She's gonna start dancing Don't worry.
You just protect me
I cannot damage the dance surely Surely she can't dance forever, right?
She surely can't dance forever That has to be impossible
There's no way There's no way she could dance forever she's gotta get tired soon She's got she's got she's gotta get tired, right?
She's just dancing through the bullets, there's no way What is door doing Sir, what the fuck are you doing?
Okay Well, i'm trying i'm trying my best i'm oh we lost door we lost door guys This is fine
Please just dance on me Just dance on me and everything will be fine
Oh my god, I told you everybody's everything will be fine if you just keep dancing Ha ha That's all you have to do
It's that easy
Okay, we're fine everything is oh no when he comes over i'm a little bit scared all right
That's fine suppressing fire
It's coming over guys
It's coming over
Bro When hulk does the hulk smash I get like actual ptsd.
I I don't know what to do
Okay, when all fails when when everything fails It's as you pull out call of duty
Come on, oh my god
Okay, okay when you know you need to try it's time to pull out call of duty Oh god, oh god, there we go Everything fails it's gun time It's
Oh, thank god call of duty is here to save the day
Clearly I gave up and just went back to cod.
I I was just like guys This is the only way Is literally the only way to shred everybody bro when the fucking hop went in because all I was so scared I was so scared.
I had a healer play cod I feel like punisher is like the most cute like he's the easiest to carry when you have a team That's a little special like that's Like I think you can play hanzo.
So you play hawkeye when you have a team you can rely on but like there's like so many characters where like I feel like there's so many characters where it's like you have to have an actual team that you can play around with but like Punisher seems seems to be one where like even my team is like special I I can like pull something off
Cause the moment I swapped to punisher my team had a It was just easier for my team My team like literally just fucking pocket me and I was fine Punisher is the team.
That's so true He's the fucking team right there All right.
Oh, we don't have a tank.
I don't want to play.
I want to heal.
I don't want to deal with No, they don't want a fucking tank either Ah We'll do All right store hold the spin lightning summon lightning restore consume jesus christ, um Let's try Okay All right that Oh, okay, and then I assume what's what's e Summon lightning to restore Oh based on a number.
Okay, we got this is the restore thing Okay, and then right click and then all right Thor is hard.
All right.
We'll see how this goes then
Yeah, thor is hard Hahaha
That's fucking right Oh fuck I I can't have to recharge Oh my god, there we go Please did our healers die?
Where's our healer?
Oh My god thor is difficult thor you have to keep track of your cooldown I don't like his cooldown shit
Yeah, i'm not a fan of the cooldown
What the fuck okay get in my circle Get in my circle Get in my circle of heals
Boom that's right smash
Okay, I should get out I gotta get out I gotta get out I got oh my god you can dance already Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad You can dance already
Oh nice, okay, that was cool though, you got a min though, that's pretty cool.
Oh no Okay, I don't like thor
I realized how I was not a fan of thor thor was not it.
Okay.
There's that okay that And then Okay How do I feel about magneto though, I don't want guys shield time I am it's time to dance It's dance time Oh my god, i'm trying my best
Please he's just holding his shield.
It's just holding his shield as if it's nothing Guys get behind me.
Oh, you know, I realized it's just there for like five seconds.
Okay.
Sorry.
I didn't
I didn't realize that, you know, it was just for five seconds guys Don't worry Oh shit get behind me
Oh, no, not hello i'm gonna go for the squirrel.
Oh Guys Oh, don't where is you?
What are you doing here?
You're stupid.
Are you stupid?
Are you Okay,
I have all Oh my god, he's holding me up Okay, I have what does the f do f is shield, right?
Yeah, okay f is shield, okay, I shouldn't have wasted that but that's okay now I know now I know
I hit That one hurts Oh, no, not the tsunami guys i'm learning please i'm not trying to learn Please i'm trying my best to figure this out I'm new here I swear to god.
I'll figure this out soon Let's see.
I gotta kill i'm figuring it out Oh He's what he's what he's so low nice He's what We gotta kill him
Nice we're fine.
All right, we did it I don't think I like magneto.
I don't Guys I don't think I like And I think I think the only reason why I don't like certain characters is just I don't understand I think if I think Guys, I think if I understand the characters I might like him more Is that such a crazy concept
I know it's so crazy If I start understanding the characters, I might actually like them Okay shield no way no fucking way doki
There nice we got the healer Tank is really strong for like just a bulky guy Okay Oh get away I figured it out Did I... did I... did I hit anything?
Guys, did I... did I hit anything?
Wait, did I hit anything?
I don't know.
Did I... did I not hit?
He was right in front of me.
Wait, what?
Did that not count?
I'm sad.
I don't know why did it hit him.
Oh my god, barrier!
Don't worry, I have shield.
What's he gonna do?
Don't worry!
No!
Okay, now we gotta leave.
As somebody that literally just played that guy, that shit is strong.
Yeah, that shit is strong.
Don't worry, guys.
Guys, I'm right here.
Guys, your other tank is right here that needs a little help.
I need healing, guys.
Guys, is that a crazy concept?
Oh, thank god.
He actually understood.
There we go.
Okay, we gotta kill this guy.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Get him!
Get the god of thunder!
No more god here!
Alright, now we can figure this out.
Clearly third time's the charm, right?
Like, we will figure this out.
Clearly I can figure out Magneto's ult here.
This is...
Third time's the fucking charm.
Oh, I had to charge it!
Oh my god!
Okay, I understand now.
I just didn't charge the stupid ult.
Oh my god.
But even then it took me like fucking forever to hit him.
Alright, see I told you.
Third time's the charm.
I told you guys.
I can't like... like the range is so low for here.
I have to wait.
Like, what was he doing?
Oh no!
Not the moon!
Please!
Anything but the moon!
Okay, maybe it's Doctor Strange time.
I don't know what was his plan.
Guys, this is real.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing.
That was a really...
That was a really bad portal.
That was actually a portal of all time.
Oh no.
No!
Guys, you guys didn't touch the payload!
Okay, I've sort of like realized about how to do the portal.
But like, I feel like I should head over.
Okay, we figured it out.
It was indeed a portal.
Oh my god.
I told you, it's a Punisher diff.
It's literally...
It's a Punisher diff.
Wait.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I'm happy that like...
DPS did more damage than me.
I would have been so sad.
I would have been really sad if DPS did not do more damage than me.
Am I like playing with console players?
Oh my god.
There's so many console players.
I don't know if I like melee DPS.
I think I like...
I like... I don't know.
I think melee DPS is like not as fun for me.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
No.
It's okay.
I'll play DPS.
Let's see.
I'm not a huge fan of melee.
I did it.
Nice.
I won!
My god, let's fucking go!
I got easiest game of my life.
I won!
I did it.
So easy.
Guys, look at that.
So fucking easy.
So good.
When you're so good the game that you win in like one second.
That's how good I am at TPS games.
I forgot this is third person.
Perfect stats?
Exactly!
It's perfect stats!
Oh my god, you're right!
Perfect.
Casey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope you had a good day today.
Please accept this super chat as thanks for always working hard.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
What do I want to try?
Should I try Iron Man?
Fire Devastate.
I want to try... Okay, let's try a new character.
Okay, we'll try Wolverine.
Alright.
We'll do a melee.
Launch up enemy.
Leap like an animal to snatch the first enemy upon impact.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Skip.
I need to read this.
Unleash a fierce howl to reduce incoming damage.
Dash forward and unleash a claw strike.
Okay, claw strike.
Claw strike.
Leap like an animal.
Reduce damage.
Okay.
And then that...
This is where I jump in and then...
Okay, we're fine.
I figured it out.
I read it.
I read it super fast.
I'll run any remaining rage builds when a Wolverine attacks or ticks it.
Okay, so I get more HP if I do more damage.
Alright.
This is fine.
We have healers.
We have one healer.
I believe in us.
Oh my god, this is so fast.
But I can only do it like... Wait, where...
Okay, guys.
Where's the... Oh, that's the objective.
I was like... Wait a minute, guys.
Yes!
I'm so angry!
That's Rookie Riot!
Oh my god, I'm so fucking mad!
I'm so angry!
Okay, alright.
It's fine.
I'm angry now.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I lose my rage if I get less angry.
Is that...
Who would've thought?
You can lose your rage when you get less...
I don't know.
I'm getting therapy, guys.
This is not good for Wolverine.
This is not good.
Oh, I'm so angry!
I'm so angry!
He's one!
He's solo!
Get him!
Nice, we got him.
They don't know I'm here.
Oh, they do.
That's Rookie Riot.
That's right, what are you gonna do?
Oh shit, you're gonna do that?
I'm still angry!
I'm still so angry!
This is so broken, holy fuck.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
How did I live that long?
Don't worry, guys.
That's Rookie Riot!
Oh!
Get over here!
I don't need therapy!
I don't...
Oh, I...
Oh, fuck.
It's fine, we won this, right?
Wolverine is amazing in 1v1.
Why are you angry?
Because I'm winning.
Hahaha!
We're fine.
We're so fine.
I don't know.
I think my team is actually good, though.
I think I'm getting like...
Yeah, like our Black Panther...
Our Black Panther actually knows how to play this game.
So I can...
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
Wait, what is my...
Whoa, shit.
What is my Q?
Ahead and spout sweeping up enemies and dealing devastating impact.
Okay, there we go.
That's fine.
That's all you and me anger.
I literally think it's...
It's...
Our...
Our Black Panther is killing really hard right now while I'm just fucking around.
Perfect time to throw when you get a stacked team.
I don't know how that feels.
This is like the first time I've actually have a team that knows what they're doing.
I'm gonna go with this guy.
I'm gonna go with Black Panther.
Okay, never mind.
Ooh, that's fucking right.
Ooh.
That's right!
I hate you specifically!
Specifically!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
Don't keep up.
You are the source of all my hate.
Nice.
Alright.
I don't know how long that buff lasts.
Tanking the thing.
It's okay.
That was worth it.
Honestly, that was so worth it.
Oh shit.
Who's dying?
Oh, they're like over here.
Don't worry, they have to get closer to me.
And they're scared.
Oh my god, yeah!
I'm fucking gonna beat you up from the sky.
I'm so angry again.
Oh shit.
Oh, guys, guys.
I don't wanna be angry anymore.
I don't wanna be angry anymore, guys.
I don't know, guys.
I regret being angry.
That's right!
I don't regret!
Die!
Okay, nice.
That's fucking right.
Who needs therapy?
Guys, you should go to therapy.
Who needs anger management class?
Who needs it?
This is my anger management class.
Oh my god.
I don't know how I'm getting away with this, actually.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm just gonna walk away.
Get down from the sky, you moth!
Oh, never mind.
I got shot in the back.
Okay, this is not fair.
They're all doing range now.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
They're all in the sky!
Wait!
That's fucked.
They all went in...
They're all in the sky now.
What am I supposed to do?
What do you do when they're in the sky?
Oh, I'm gonna watch Venom die.
There's no way.
Alright, this is good.
That's fucking right!
Fuck you in particular!
Where are you?
Oh, you think you can get away?
Oh shit.
Oh shit, he's...
Woah!
Let me just...
Let me just walk away.
Let me just walk away real fast.
Woah!
I just saw a storm and I just...
backed off.
World's most nicest kidney eating character.
Oh my god, two in a row.
I never...
I never knew how that felt like until today.
Oh my god.
This is the first time...
I got experienced two in a row.
Two... oh yeah, guys.
Yeah.
Oh thank god I didn't have to carry.
Thank fucking god.
I like that.
I like actually being able to fuck around instead of swapping to Punisher.
Thank fucking god.
Alright, let's see.
What do I want to play this time?
I feel like I played almost all the new characters.
Oh, I don't want to play Tekken right now.
I don't really.
Alright.
It's fine.
It's time to actually play Loki.
This is fine.
We finally get a chance to try out Loki.
I wonder if they buffed him or if he's like the same as Beta.
For those who don't know, like the...
The Beta version was like...
Alpha was like super OP and then Beta was like...
The Beta version was like really weak.
What was E?
Oh.
Okay.
And then...
Snap, okay.
Oh girl, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's try.
Snap!
I forgot about...
Whoops.
I forgot about my other Loki shadow.
I was like, wait a minute, I went backwards.
That doesn't seem right.
How did I go backwards?
Oh, Black Panther, I can't heal you like this!
I can't heal you!
Stay in my zone!
Come on guys, one kill!
One kill guys!
Come on guys!
Oh, that's fine!
I didn't guess we all die!
That's okay!
Like, we don't have to be alive or anything.
Like, that's okay!
Guys, just...
One kill!
Oh, that's okay!
We'll eventually get that one kill guys!
Guys?
We're gonna get that one kill, right?
Right, guys?
Don't worry.
Is it because we don't have a tank?
No, we do.
We have two tanks now.
Okay, I can...
Alright, get in there!
Get in there!
Use the heal!
Use the ultimate heal orb!
Oh my god, please!
Don't make me become you!
I'm gonna become you now!
That's fucking right!
I'm gonna eat you!
Oh, I fucking... I made a mistake!
I don't want... I made a mistake!
I'm so sorry!
Guys, please!
Please, guys!
Please!
Okay...
I...
I think my team is struggling!
I think...
I...
I think my team is not doing so well.
I don't know yet!
I'm not sure.
I'm trying my best to keep them all up though.
Okay, the more clones I have, the more like...
Okay, there you go.
You can't kill me now.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Oh my god, please just kill one.
Guys, team, team, team, team, team!
There's so many bubbles!
Just pick up a bubble!
Our sheriff gave so many bubbles for you!
Our sheriff kept giving you bubbles!
Bubbles!
All they did was give you bubbles!
Oh my god, guys, this is it!
Guys, please!
Please, we got killed!
Move up, move up, move up!
They're scared of the bubbles.
Oh my god, we finally made it!
We finally made it here!
It only took us one minute and twenty...
We only have one minute.
There we go.
This makes it so that...
Me pressing shift makes it so that they can't kill us.
Okay, nice.
What the fuck?
No!
Let me go!
Oh god, I'm alive!
I'm alive!
Oh my god, thank fucking god, I'm alive!
Oh thank god!
That scared me, I thought...
Oh my god!
I got saved, but it didn't matter!
Shark boy!
Bro, the shark boy...
He's so scary!
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm gonna be the shark.
If I'm beating the shark, it'll be fine.
Stand in there, stand in there!
Stand in there!
We gotta get the shark, we gotta get the shark!
Where is he?
Where is he so I can steal his ability?
I need to steal his!
Yes!
Get over there.
That's fine!
That's fine, we got it!
Oh my god, that actually...
That actually clutched it.
That actually clutched it for us.
Oh my god, I swallowed them up!
So they could...
We don't deserve this win.
I don't think we're even gonna win, guys.
We absolutely do not deserve.
Like, oh my god.
I don't think...
I don't think we deserve it.
Bro, the ult is so fucking crazy.
We would've lost if I didn't do that.
We actually would've lost.
Like, that's the saddest part.
The fact that we would've lost if we did not...
If I didn't swallow.
Oh my god, he's gonna do it!
He's gonna do it!
Sharkboy, where are you?
Don't worry, Sharkboy!
Oh no, oh my god, he got Void too.
I just saw a man get Void.
I just saw...
Alright, bro, fuck this.
I don't trust my team.
It's time.
It's fucking time.
It's time to dance.
I don't think I can...
I can be the shark.
I don't think I can pull another shark move.
Jesus!
Oh shit!
It's fine, we're fine.
Guys!
Please!
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, clap!
Clap!
No!
I'm trying to clap as hard as I can!
Oh!
Sharkboy, no!
Sharkboy!
It's fine.
I got him.
Bro, Icegirl does so much healing.
It's actually crazy.
She does so much.
Now we dance.
Please don't.
Please don't forward me.
Please, I can't.
Please.
Please, I can't dance anymore.
The dancing stops now!
Guys, I can't keep dancing, guys!
Please, no!
No!
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god.
No!
He fucking...
Oh my god, this shark is so strong!
I had a
feeling we weren't going to win that.
The only reason we got the point was because I fucking boarded them.
That was the only reason.
That was literally the only reason we were able to get that point.
I was like...
I went...
And then we won.
We got the point.
But the shark is so strong!
Yeah!
I think the shark is meta.
Don't play shark.
Now it's my turn.
Now it's my turn to be the shark.
I feel like he is.
I feel like if you can coordinate...
If you can coordinate getting all the...
Because they can't leave this fucking mouth!
That's the worst part.
You can't leave his mouth!
Shark boy, where is lava girl?
True.
We're going to be on a plane!
Oh nice, we got a team up.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, he's so cute!
Look at him!
I'm ready for...
I think his right click is really strong too.
Not gonna lie.
Oh wait, is it ice shark powers?
Oh, it's because it's a team up!
Oh, we have like the team up ability now.
Now I'm like fast too when I shift.
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
Copyright distinct free.
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble!
Don't worry!
I spit!
Bubble, bubble, bubble!
Reload!
Reloading my mouth!
Bubble!
Reloading mouth!
Okay, we gotta head over to heal them.
Jesus Christ, that's so much damage.
What the fuck?
Why do I do so much damage?
That's crazy.
I'm reloading my mouth.
I was not expecting that much damage.
Bubble, bubble, take my bubbles.
Okay, spit the water.
Get over here!
Did I lead the shot?
Okay, let's see if I can grab him.
Yeah, I don't think he's gonna... yeah.
Oh!
It's okay.
We're fine, we're fine, we're okay, we're so safe.
I'll restock on the bubbles for us.
Just take the bubbles.
And my mouth is reloaded.
That's okay.
Just go up, go up!
Why are you scared?
He's so low!
All he has are his hands!
See, I got you.
I'm spitting!
It's okay.
Jesus Christ.
He has to be meta.
His damage is actually so strong.
His heals are really good too.
Guys, this is what I meant.
I think I can solo him.
I think I can!
That's my boy Jeff!
Go Jeff!
Oh my god, I literally solo'd a ting myself.
A chaos streak as a healer.
Yeah, that's actually crazy.
Wait, Jeff is so fucking OP.
Wait, this isn't fair!
The fuck?
I think it's Jeff and the fairy.
What's her name?
Luna Fairy?
I think it's Jeff and Luna Fairy as the meta healers.
Swim up walls, watch.
Okay, not.
See?
Okay, I had to...
I can wall climb.
I just don't do it because there's no point.
Oh, Luna Snow.
I thought she was a fairy.
Let's go.
Oh no, they can see my fin.
They can see my...
They can see my fin and stuff if I try to...
Don't worry!
Take the...
Take it!
It's okay, I can solo him!
Okay, somebody has to capture though.
My mouth has been reloaded.
Every time I eat, I reload.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, I can all...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit, oh shit, Magneto, no!
That's fucking right.
You don't get this.
I'm stronger than you, Magneto!
I've got the...
This is so bullshit for you!
I have the bubble!
I'm so stupid.
I...
That's actually so stupid.
Holy shit.
These poor guys.
I don't think they want to play anymore.
Oh, Jeff, you think you can Jeff this?
There can only be one Jeff here.
Oh, I'm gonna back away a little bit though.
There can only be one Jeff.
That's fine.
That's why I got you.
Take the bubble!
Oh, he couldn't.
He didn't take the bubble.
It's okay, I reloaded a little.
Fine.
He doesn't know.
I had to flee!
I just kept...
Oh my god, he had to get his friend to help.
He had to get another support to help him.
That's insane.
That's so stupid.
Oh my god, I love Jeff.
His name...
What?
What happened?
That's what...
Okay.
Jeff...
Jeff was not feeling it that time.
He was not feeling it.
But don't worry, Jeff is coming over.
Oh, Jeff is coming over.
Oh, he died in my mouth.
He died.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay, we still win.
Whoops.
I'm sorry.
I think the worst part is that I griefed my other support player.
It was worth it.
If I can't...
If I couldn't spit out the other guy, I'll spit somebody else out.
There can only be one support.
KD!
No!
We still won.
We still won though, guys.
We did it, everybody.
Someone's gotta get spit.
Someone's gotta get spat out.
Oh my god, it's gonna be fucking forever until I get to level 10.
Yay!
Yippee!
Okay, I think Jeff is...
Honestly, of all the new characters, Jeff is the most fun one out of all of them.
I find.
Why is that friendly fire?
It's cause it's fall damage.
It was an accident, guys.
An accident.
Alright, let's...
Let's be Squirrel Girl again.
I think Squirrel Girl is fun.
Literally all I did was just throw nuts.
Can use as an ability without cooldown once.
Reload burst acorns and can use an ability without cooldown once.
What's burst acorn?
Oh, it reloads this for me.
Oh!
Okay.
Unleash.
Guards.
Imprisoning the first one.
Now it's back to Squirrel Girl.
I think all the new characters are really fun.
But the only main concern is that I don't like how majority of the new characters...
Majority of the new characters are melee based.
That's the only thing I'm not like...
Like, I'm not like really a fan of.
Let's see.
That's... Okay.
I just need to figure out my cooldowns.
It's time.
I don't need more melee.
I just need a pew-pew.
Strongest hero in the world.
Oh, it's defense.
I feel like I've been playing defense so much.
Who's your favorite to play so far?
I think if I want to win, it's...
I won't say he's like the most fun.
It's like, if I want to... WHAT THE FUCK?!
If I want to win, I have to play Punisher.
That's really it.
Oh my god.
Bro, he just jumps away from my acorns!
There we go.
Nice, I trapped somebody.
I think fun-wise, I actually really enjoy...
I really enjoy...
Oh my god.
Jeff.
Jeff is actually...
Jeff is the most fun, but if I want to win, I play Luna Snow and Punisher.
I think...
Okay, nice.
Get another one!
Nice, I imprisoned one!
Let's go!
There we go.
Literally, all I have to do is just do this in the corner.
That's all I have to do.
And then I can get high ground here and then do this in the corner too.
What are you gonna do, fucking...
What are you gonna do, dodge it?
That's right, you can't do jack shit.
Oh my god.
Quick, he's... Oh shit, he's angry!
He's so angry!
Somebody stop him, he's so fucking mad!
Oh my god, we stopped him.
Bro, they're all melee!
They're all melee!
What do we do?
What do we do when they're all melee?
Guys, please!
Please!
Where's my team?
I've stayed alive for so long!
Oh my god, how am I still alive?
Movement, literally movement.
I literally movement the shit out of all of them, that was crazy.
It was just a pow- oh no, he's so mad.
He's actually so mad.
Oh my god.
I had like- so like, her ability is that she can...
Jesus Christ, what the fuck?!
Oh my god, the angry...
Oh no, is it time?
Is it time?
Do I wanna win?
Is it I wanna win time, guys?
Guys, I think...
Guys, I think it's I wanna win time.
I think...
I think it's I really wanna win.
I think it's time.
I really, really wanna win.
Okay.
Oh my god, I have to die though if I wanna do what I wanna do.
Please!
Please, I'm trying so hard!
Thank god!
Just run in!
Run in, my squirrels!
Nice.
Oh god.
Oh god, I am trying my best.
Oh my god, nice!
I'm literally- I'm just chucking!
I'm chucking squirrels!
All I do is chuck squirrels!
I haven't stopped chucking!
Okay, nice.
I haven't stopped chuck- Oh, fuck!
Angry Canadian!
I lived!
I don't know how!
I don't know how I- Oh my god.
How the fuck?
Please!
It's okay, we beat the angry Canadian.
We beat myself, technically.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's the Venom power-up.
My god, please!
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
It's time to actually try to win.
The squirrel hunts the wolverine.
Frank, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
That's right, what are you gonna do with your fucking fists?
What are you fucking gonna do with your fucking fists?
Alright, this is it.
Because they have so many melee characters, this is literally the perfect time.
Bro, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Where is- Okay!
As I told you guys, if I wanna win...
If I- If I wanna win, this is what I have to do.
This is what I have to do.
This is the- What the fuck?
Bro, the venom shit?
He's so low!
If I wanna win, it's Cod.
Yep.
I cast gun.
They wanna
use their fists?
I bring gun.
Oh shit!
There's two- They two of them fisted!
The most powerful spell of all time.
Exactly.
All I have to do is just shoot.
And then if they get too close, I have a turret.
The only- The only reason- Honestly, the only reason they won that fight was literally because- Was literally because two of them started hitting me.
Bro, stop!
Stop!
Fucking- Oh shit, I'm born again.
Let's go.
He's one.
Please.
This guy is so fucking fast though.
He's really good.
Oh my god, please.
I really need heals though.
Oh my god, where's the heal pack?
Please.
I'm trying so hard to help you.
I have no HP.
Oh my god, thank god.
Please, no!
I lived for so long!
And it's fire and does 200 flips!
I actually lived for so long!
All I needed was heals!
Oh my god.
I gotta live though.
No!
It's all- I'm so close to my ult!
I don't think I got heals during the last fight.
I don't- I don't think.
Heals.
My heals.
My heals left the chat.
I just need it.
Spare me some heals.
Spare me some heals, everyone, please.
Just a little morsel.
Just a crumb.
Just a fucking crumb.
I wish Punisher has heals.
No heals.
Alright, let's see.
What have I not played yet?
Um...
I never really liked Scarlet Witch.
I know she- Like, I know she's her- Her ult is like a D.Va mom.
But I've never really liked it.
It's not- Honestly, it's not my favorite.
Fucking Cloak and Dagger confused the shit out of me.
Oh, we don't have a tank, but that's okay.
Oh yeah, we can try Moon Knight!
Wait, I forgot about him!
Wait, I want- We don't need a healer.
Alright, how do I play- How do I play- How do I play Moon Batman- Moon Man?
Open a portal that allows us to bombard and enter a gliding state and to knock enemies when airborne towards the center.
Launch a front grapple that pulls- Okay, perform a combo with his and the third strike will slightly launch the enemy.
Perform a double jump- Launch that can bounce between- Okay.
Alright.
Just that.
What does that do again?
What does the E do?
To knock enemies when- Oh, it knocks people.
Oh, okay.
What the- Holy shit, what?
Wait.
Jesus, what?
What is this DPS?
Wait, that's crazy.
What the fuck?
What is this fucking DPS there?
His DPS is actually crazy, not gonna lie.
I'm gonna- Look at that!
Okay, I think- I think his DPS is a little broken.
I legitimately think it is a little bit- Like, what am I doing?
What am I doing?
Just Moon- Run, you bullshit bitch!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
I love random
damage!
Jesus Christ!
That's actually crazy, I already did 2000 damage.
The only bad thing is that I definitely need heals.
It's just like the memes!
I love random bullshit!
He's kinda like a glass cannon, but like- If I get pocketed, it's actually crazy.
It's actually crazy how strong he is.
Wait, how do I use his ult though?
Oh god.
That's right!
With the power of the moon!
I still don't really understand the E though.
He's got the same health as Jeff.
I need help.
What does the E actually do?
Like, what does it do?
Okay.
That's fine.
He's almost dead, but he's getting heals.
You attack it so it will- Oh!
Wait, oh my god, wait!
It's like a geometry!
Simple geometry!
Oh god, I'm sorry, I was figuring out- Yeah.
Oh my god, I- Oh my god, it's like simple geometry!
Shapes!
Oh my god, it's like fucking shapes, guys!
Jesus Christ.
I don't think this is- This does not look fair.
That's a good girl!
Maybe you're better than Batman.
He's straight!
Wait, why have I not been playing him this entire time?
Woo!
Shapes!
I love shapes!
Jesus Christ, this is so dumb.
This is actually so dumb.
Okay.
We're fine.
We got shapes here.
I literally am just throwing shapes down here.
I'm just throwing shapes and killing people down here.
Easy.
Oh shit.
Don't make me throw a shape!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna fucking do it!
You know I can!
I'm gonna fucking throw geometry in here!
That's crazy.
I think I found my favorite character.
Don't make me pull a shape!
Don't fucking- Oh shit!
I was gonna say, fucking easy with it.
That's right, moon time.
That's right, it's moon time!
Oh, I messed up the shape though.
Get closer!
Get closer to my shape!
Okay.
Guys, I need you guys to get closer.
Come on!
He's so low!
Is he okay down there?
Ow.
I'm so tired.
You look so tired.
I am so tired.
It's okay, I'll throw shapes down here.
Okay.
Shape time!
Where's my shape?
That's right, stand here!
Nice.
Damn, how did you know?
Yay!
You know...
I should've been playing him in the beginning, not gonna lie.
I...
I feel like...
Oh, yeah!
I...
Oh, yeah, 100%!
Maybe I should've played him at the very start, like, not gonna lie.
I think, like, we know...
I think we know who's the best character here.
I think he's, like, super squishy.
But...
His DPS is actually insane.
His DPS...
The DPS is fucking crazy.
I, like, fucking threw one...
One shape at them, and then it was like...
No!
My shape!
No, shape man!
No!
What do I do when I can't play shape man?
What can I do?
No!
I can't be a moon!
I don't know.
I don't know what to do when I can't play that.
It's time for Widowmaker.
They took all our shapes.
Oh shit, nice!
We can wall toge- We can shoot the targets!
What is the world without shape?
Exactly!
There's one reason why I love playing Widowmaker.
No, there's two reasons why I like playing Black Widow.
Guys...
Guys, I need help.
Please, he's one!
Please, he's solo!
Nice!
Come on, peek me!
That's not fair.
That's fucking right, bitch.
No!
Please, I got three solo kills!
Please!
Oh my god, that was such a carry!
Three!
But yeah, I love Black Widow for two main reasons.
Two big main reasons.
Guys!
Guys, no!
You can just do that?
Oh my god, Jesus Christ.
That shit's insane.
You can just walk up to me.
I got rushed so hard.
Hey, Hawkeye.
You like, help?
But like, I don't know.
I don't know if you know what that means.
Okay.
He's one.
Please, he's solo.
Are you serious?
He's so low!
He's so bad!
No, I didn't mean that!
I was just joking!
I was joking, guys!
Guys, please turn around!
Okay, that's actually like...
They let him do that?!
I hate my...
My team didn't even help me!
That's actually crazy!
My team ignored...
Holy fuck!
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Like, I'm mad.
That's it.
That's fucking it.
It's time.
It's fucking time.
I'm so mad at my team.
That's fucking it.
They took...
Wait, I can play Moonman!
I'm gonna play Moonman after this.
I'm gonna play Moonman.
No more.
I'm not...
I'm not fucking around anymore.
I'm not fucking around no more.
Did you guys all leave the point?!
What?!
Oh my god!
How did you all leave the point?!
Holy shit!
How the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I'm fucking...
I'm not playing around no more.
I have no team.
I am the darkness.
This is my...
This is my Joker arc right here.
I still can't believe...
He fucking ran past...
My entire team!
And like my healer...
Ignored me!
Like...
Do you have eyes?
Oh, his name is Slowpoke.
He does not.
Okay.
He absolutely did not have eyes.
God.
Oh my god.
It's time for random bullshit time.
Jesus Christ.
What?!
Eventually something's gonna hit.
That's fucking right.
I'm fucking angry.
I'm shaped, man.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Light!
With the power of light!
And the moon!
I don't know, that's...
I think it's a waste, but...
Nice, okay.
Where is he?
Get over here.
That's fine.
Okay, as long as he's not Moonman, that's fine.
I'm just gonna stay here.
That's fine.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We just stay back here.
Oh shit, it's not fine.
With the power of light!
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
I don't...
Oh no.
I'm fucking leaving.
You can have it.
Holy shit.
He can have the point.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of his clones real fast though.
Alright, that's fucking right!
Get over here!
It's shape time!
Oh shit, maybe not.
No way!
Oh my god, I jumped!
I fucking jumped!
Team, please.
Team, I...
I really...
Team, please.
A little assistance.
I can't solo at all, guys.
I know you guys think I can.
But I don't think I can, guys.
I...
Oh my god, I wish...
I wish I can solo it all.
Oh no, not Hella.
It's fine.
I don't think he realized.
There we go.
Oh, I got the moon.
We got the moon, it's fine.
We literally got the moon on our side.
We got shapes and moons.
We stay here.
We're the most ultimate shape right here.
Oh my god, I see him.
Fuck you!
That's right!
I remember what you did!
That's fucking right!
Get down!
There were all the lucky charms at him.
Oh my god, all I had to be was moon man.
I know what you did last summer.
I remember that.
Wait, I still have to do another objective.
Oh my god, I forgot.
I thought I won.
I was gonna be ready to fucking type in chat and be like, fucking get good.
I was so ready to type in chat like, GG's gay fucking good.
You fucking idiot.
I have better aim, you fucker.
You just had a better team that would literally protect- that actually defend you.
My team would rather I fucking die.
They don't care.
They don't care about me.
Whee!
My team doesn't care.
They're just like, you're still here?
I'm like, please guys.
Please.
Alright.
This is it.
Guys, I have- I'm sort of like, I don't know guys.
I'm scared that we might not win this, guys.
Guys, what if we don't win this, guys?
What if?
What would I do?
I don't know what to do.
What the fuck?
Get me away from here.
Oh shit!
Oh my gosh!
Hey guys, I really would appreciate...
If he gets near me, if he gets near me, I swear to god, I'm ready to shape this right now.
Oh shit!
I guess I wasn't...
I wasn't ready to shape this.
Please.
I'm so scared because I'm 1 HP.
Oh my god!
I'm having a heart attack right now.
My blood pressure is not doing okay.
I'm so scared.
Oh fuck!
Oh my god, please.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, my cover.
Oh my god, please, there's so many people.
Just stay there.
Oh my god, he keeps fucking...
Please, no!
Wait, we got 42%.
That's fine.
Oh my god, the walls are falling.
I don't know what to do when the walls start falling.
My entire plan was to rely on cover, but then my cover is not forever.
That's so fucked up.
That moment when your walls are not forever.
Like, what do you do?
What do you do when your walls are not forever?
You know what, fuck this one guy.
It's alright, their support is gone!
Their support ran away!
Oh my god, he fucking shot my thing.
Bro, he's just flying everywhere.
Guys, what do I do when they keep hitting my chain?
Bro, he just flies.
Bro, fuck this.
He just keeps flying.
I don't know what to do when he does that.
Oh my god.
No!
I didn't mean to grapple!
Guys, this is a harder to play Moon Knight.
I think it's time.
I think it's time to pull the Punisher.
This is way...
My platforms keep falling.
It's time for the ultimate.
It's like when you swapped a Bastion.
During the last...
It's exactly like when you swapped a Bastion during the last second.
When you were there, I could hear you.
I could hear you.
It's exactly when you swapped a Bastion.
Oh shit!
Oh no.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best, guys.
I'm so close to ult.
Is it?
We got the support.
That's fine.
It's me!
He needed some death!
Oh my god!
You just needed to dance!
You just needed to keep dancing!
He like ran away from me.
I'm so confused.
You know those moments when...
When your healer just runs away?
Like, what do you do?
Guys, I think it's GG.
Guys.
No.
No way.
Yes!
We did it!
Oh my god!
Dude,
you're too old.
Yeah.
Wait, how did you know?
How did you know?
It's my birthday today.
Yes!
Like, what do you mean?
Yes, of course!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Bro, I never had to work so hard for this.
I never had to work so fucking hard for this stupid game.
Oh my god.
This match, I actually tried so fucking hard.
Because of this fucker.
Dude, fuck this guy.
This guy was the bait of my existence.
I had to win that game.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
I hate my team.
I hate my...
I actually...
I hate my team.
And I hate my enemy team.
Oh my god.
I still can't believe they like, ran...
I had the fucking Star Lord chase me around for like 50 fucking years.
And then he ran through my team to kill me.
Like, the healer didn't even look at me.
Oh my god.
That was so bullshit.
That was actually the game that like, broke me.
That was the moment where I was like, that's it.
That's fucking it.
I'm gonna put them in their place.
They don't deserve this win.
None of them do, but I won the win.
I'm here to make everybody else miserable.
Oh my god.
That was my canon event.
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
But, before I end it.
I do have a special announcement.
I do have a very special announcement.
Oh, not these though.
Sorry, this was me shilling stuff.
Alright, so.
So, yes.
Special announcement time.
That was fun though.
I had a lot of fun in Marble Rivals.
I thought I could get to level 10.
Before the end of the stream.
But I definitely did not get to level 10.
Cause I really wanted to try out rank.
But, oh my god.
It was so too difficult.
It took so long.
It took so fucking long.
To even like, grind.
To like, level 7.
I think I got to level 7.
And that was the furthest I got.
But it was definitely really fun.
It...
It opened a very toxic side of me.
It definitely...
Gave me an incredibly toxic side of me.
While I was playing.
So, yeah.
For sure.
I definitely think my favorite characters.
Was Jeff.
It was Jeff.
It was Jeff and then.
For healing.
And DPS wise.
Has to be.
Oh my god, that's difficult.
DPS wise.
It's really difficult.
Because a lot of them are really fun.
If I want to win.
I pick Punisher.
Because it's literally...
Oh, shape.
Moon.
Moon Knight is my favorite.
Definitely.
Moon Knight.
Moon Knight is my favorite DPS.
Tank wise, I hope I never have to fucking play tank again.
I think tank is...
I'm sorry.
Just like every other game.
Tank is not fun at all.
Tank was so not fun.
I was fucking struggling.
I was like, no, not again.
Let me out of my prison cell.
Let me out.
Alright.
So.
The announcement.
Also, Zacona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
First timer here pulled an all nighter to tune in.
Figured that today I'm turning a year older.
I want to let the best VTuber know.
My last bit of money before eating ice.
Thank you so much for your very first super chat.
I hope you enjoyed Marble Rivals.
And that you had fun.
Watching Marble Rivals.
It is free to play.
I know I didn't play any of the melee characters.
I personally don't really enjoy melee that much.
I like pointing at things and shooting.
That's what I like.
I'm not a melee fan.
I just like pointing at stuff.
And then go pew, pew, pew.
That's really it.
But yeah, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Sagona.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
Yeah.
Well, I played Wolverine.
I thought it was really funny.
But I feel like I was only able to pull this off.
Because I actually had a team.
That knew what they were doing.
So all I did was just run in.
And go...
I'm angry.
And then fucking die.
So that's really it.
But like...
I tried overplaying melee characters before.
But I just got like super...
What's the word?
I get so like...
Not dizzy.
But like...
I don't know where I am.
What's that word?
Because the melee characters, you have to be able to move around so much.
Movement wise.
Disoriented.
Yeah, I get so disoriented when I play melee characters.
So I never...
I remember trying it during beta.
I tried it during beta.
And I was so fucking disoriented.
Because I don't know where to go.
And so I just...
I gave up on melee characters.
Because it's not for me.
I can't do that.
Hey guys.
Alright, special announcement.
So...
Wow!
Okay, so...
I'm gonna show you guys...
Something really pretty cool.
So...
My very, very, very, very...
Special announcement.
Is...
Oh wait, let me give me a sec.
I'm stalling even more.
With anticipation.
What could it be?
Wow!
Alright, so...
I will send something very special...
To show you guys.
And...
This very special thing is...
Drumroll please.
Yes!
It's the Nendoroid!
There it is!
The Nendoroid!
The unpainted version.
Oh wait...
That's not all.
Juki, what do you mean that's not all?
Because...
The unpainted version...
...was just the bait!
It's fully painted!
That's right!
Because pre-orders are coming very, very soon!
What do you mean by very soon, Doki?
As in, pre-orders will be this month in December.
So keep your eyes peeled...
...on when it'll be officially.
I requested...
The great thing about the proc... Like...
I actually got a request exactly what I wanted for my Nendoroid.
So, like, I get to request, like, what accessories I wanted...
...and, like, what type of expressions I wanted.
So, like, for accessories, I was like...
I need a croaky and a tomato in there.
I need croaky, tomato, and a dragoon.
And they were able to do all three for me.
But that means I don't have, like, a lot of hand accessories.
I think I only have, like, one hand accessory or something.
So... So...
But I thought it was worth it.
I honestly thought it was so fucking worth it.
Because, like, you know, like, it's just so me...
...to have, like, the tomato and croaky in there with me.
So, like, it was, like, the one thing I really wanted.
So...
Yeah, I thought it was much better than hand accessories.
So you can actually have, like, little croaky and the little tomato me over there.
So, yes!
Yes!
So here's the...
Here's the unpainted version, and here's the painted version.
I'm so... Oh my god.
It have everything... They work so fast, honestly.
And I'm really happy with how it turned out.
It actually looks so fucking good.
Like, the colors look amazing.
And, like, the details and everything.
And I'll be tweeting this out later as well.
So, yeah!
That's my special announcement!
It's gonna... Pre-orders will be very, very soon!
It's gonna be in December.
So keep your eyes peeled for December on when it's actually officially out.
I can't say when yet.
I can't say when, but it's definitely very soon this month!
So, yeah!
I'm super excited, guys.
I'm, like, running on fumes right now.
That... That Marble Rivals stream...
Fucked me up.
But, I hope you guys are super excited.
Also, by the way, today is the last day to vote for me for VTuber Awards.
So, I am up for several categories.
I'm up for Best VTuber, VTuber of the Year, FPS VTuber of the Year...
But, Best Event, which will be WrestleTuber.
And Best Fandom, which is you guys, Dragoons!
So, yeah!
Please vote!
Today's the last day!
I really want to win at least one thing.
And I hope... If anything, I hope it's, like, you know...
If we win only one thing, I hope it's Best Fandom.
Because you guys did so much for me.
Like, I couldn't have gotten Nendoroid without you guys.
Also, by the way, if you guys want Courage Doki, Bounty Hunter Doki Nendoroid...
We have enough cells to qualify for that.
Hint, hint, nudge, nudge.
So, obviously, if you see a lot of appeal, a lot of, like, people buying Retro Doki, we might be able to get Bounty Hunter Doki if we have enough cells for it.
So, yeah!
That's basically it, guys!
Thank you all for coming, everybody!
I had a great time playing Marble Rivals.
Honestly, like, my thoughts on Marble Rivals so far is that...
I don't find it competitive.
I just find it as, like, me being toxic.
Like, that's really it.
I don't... I don't... I don't think it's, like...
I personally don't think it's, like, super competitive so far.
I think it's fun.
It's, like, a head-empty type deal.
Fun type.
But also, I think it's also because I'm not playing ranked, though.
But it's definitely really fun.
Um, there's a lot of, like...
There's definitely a lot of a learning curve on some of the characters.
Like, I can't do melee.
I legitimately can't.
Like, I see the melee buttons.
Like, all the buttons for melee characters.
And I'm like, what the fuck am I doing?
Like...
I was like, I don't know what the fuck I'm supposed to do here.
So... So...
Um, but we'll see.
We'll see.
I still... Honestly, I think if it was the first person, I'd definitely enjoy it a lot more.
Um, uh...
But yeah, thank you everybody for coming.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
I'm gonna zoom in.
Oh my god, look at her.
Oh my god, look.
Oh my god, look at me here.
Look, that's me.
And then that's also me.
And then that's me too!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'll see you guys later, guys.
Bye bye!